[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
speed chess tournament can you keep up
that's crazy for the last seven years
and counting the best Blitz and bullet
players in the world have flocked to
chess.com to prove their worth at this
format dominant display one of the best
SCC performances that I have ever seen
in seven years dozens have tried but
only two have ever worn this Crown
Magnus makes it look easy
wins the speed test Championship spits
in a row who will be this year's Blitz
King
welcome to the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase
[Music]
okay ladies and gentlemen welcome to
another epic semi-final of the speed
Chess Championship presented by coinbase
as Hikaru Nakamura the five-time SEC
Champion takes on the Frenchman with two
names no three names Maxim vashia lagrav
while International Master Casa Corley
has two names and he is my co-host today
I'm Grandmaster Daniel nerdinsky Casa
good afternoon to you I can't wait can
you
Dania pleasure to be with you today uh
it's just going to be an incredible
matchup and yeah we have two Titans of
Chess basically going at it at multiple
time controls what what's not to like
what's not to like indeed I think the
only proper way to set the tone if
you're a viewer is to watch The Game of
Thrones opening credits scene so epic is
this match which will begin at 12 noon
eastern time yes that is eight minutes
from now I see Karo will take on mvl to
determine who qualifies to the final and
challenges Magnus Carlson Casa speaking
of Magnus Carlson he more than took care
of business yesterday with a 15-point
spread against Wesley so crazy yeah it
was nearing adoption territory yesterday
and when Magnus is just has that flow
and he's motivated it's just extremely
dangerous but we shouldn't discount what
hakara has done along this journey as
well because I can even recall in his
first match against you yangi yangi
putting up incredible fight and still
trailing and that's what it seems like
when Nakamura is in great form so he had
a dominant performance against carwana
there was some trickiness in the five
plus one segment once that was navigate
dated it was a wash after that so really
interesting to see what happens today
well there's only one way to find out
and that is for the two of them to play
now I mentioned that Hikaru has won uh
the SEC five times he's won it five
times in a row starting from 2018. that
was a very different looking Magnus
Carlson in 2016 and 2017. after that it
was all Hikaru and look at the people
that he beat in the final we are playing
a rematch from the 2020 final today last
year that was one of the most famous
online matches of all time as he defeats
Magnus Carlson by one point Casa this
year promises to be perhaps even more
epic yeah no question and look we've had
two guys essentially have a Stranglehold
on the SCC but mvl is one of the guys
that's actually made the final he's
beaten uh Carlson to make the final
before and so he's no stranger to
actually a really significant upset and
that might be the case today so that's
why we're all watching
indeed we are well Hikaru Nakamura we
were watching his previous match against
Fabiano caruana very carefully and it
was worth a serious watch because Hikaru
put in a vintage Hikaru performance a
wire to wire Victory across all time
formats it started off pretty close but
as he's done so many times in the past
Hikaru ran away with it in the three
minute portion
yeah and again he is so dominant the
faster the time control gets and that
was a theme in the previous match you
know Fabi would play objectively really
good chess but when the time scrambles
came to the four we were commenting that
match together you know stuff happens
and so that's going to be the question
how does mvl navigate those time
scrambles that akaro does so well and in
I mean you can't sugarcoat it when
you're playing Hikaru Nakamura you no
matter how you slice it and you're gonna
have to put in one of the performances
of your life if you even want to stay in
the match average accuracy was pretty
high for both thakamura and caruana but
when you can keep those blunders down
Casa to single digits that's what makes
you such a scary opponent and that is
the commonality between Carlson's
matches and hikaru's matches this year
in the SEC single digit blunders
yeah and again it's it's really
basically even when the time control
quickens to still make steady moves that
keep the game going asking important
questions
um and that really is going to be the
test now Magnus actually said yesterday
that he feels that Maxim's chance really
is going to come down to how well he
uses the white pieces
um how well he's able to put pressure on
NACA early and uh do you agree with that
Donya or do you think there's other
things to this match too I completely
agree I think if we take all of the SEC
matches for this one openings might
actually be the deciding factor in
determining whether mvl has a serious
chance to stay in the match uh by his
own admission
but also based on mvl's match against
nihal sarin which propelled him to the
semi-finals this was one of the most
impressive displays of the SEC thus far
Casa I think you'll co-sign that point
it wasn't just the fact that Maxine
defeated nihal it was the way that he
did it after an early deficit he never
looked back he wins all three sections
with clean crisp tactically proficient
chess and nihald really never stood a
chance which we don't say very often
yeah and I think at some point in that
match I'm not mistaken MPL was leading
each segment 636-363
um which was like really unusual and
just kind of underscored the dominance
and yeah mvl is someone who really does
uh play reasonably uh really as the time
control quickens he's not someone that I
feel like is gonna have as much of a
struggle in the three plus one the one
plus one because he's done it before so
that's going to be interesting for me to
see
yeah and to bring it back to openings
envio was constantly able to steer the
game in the direction that made him
comfortable with white he was getting
sharp positions with black against the
Hall's London system and Queen's Gambit
he was getting precisely the kind of
solid position in which he understands
the ideas can he repeat that against
Hikaru Nakamura in this match well
speaking of repeats this match is a
repeat of their SCC Final in 2020 feels
like eons ago but that was only a couple
of years back a convincing Victory by
Hikaru Nakamura Casa where in this
graphic will mvl have to kind of
counteract The Narrative and depart from
The Arc of their match in 2020. yeah
folks this is in rocket science the
eight to three Advantage for Nakamura in
the OnePlus One told the story and that
is going to be the essentially the
adjustment where the game where the game
is won or lost essentially so we'll see
if MPL does have some good adjustments
today I also to point out that
MBO is someone that you know we
traditionally know as a schoonfeld
player um and in recent years he's
really deviated quite a bit particularly
in online control so for me it's like is
he gonna have some Queen's gamut
acceptance today some Slavs he's really
messed around with a lot of different
setups and I think that's going to be
key uh in this match
it most certainly will be well speaking
of keys to the match we want to take a
look at our Deloitte game analytics
we're thrilled to have Deloitte a leader
in their field as the official Data
Insights partner for the speed Chess
Championship their dedication to
Excellence aligns perfectly with the
chess.com mission to grow the game and
the sport of Chess let's dive in to page
one take a look at the details behind
this match obviously Hikaru has the
higher chess.com Blitz rating he is
nearing 3300 and look at those massive
massive head-to-head scores casa yeah
Nakamura is killing it in the Blitz and
in the bullet um and I also want to
point out here you know chess is a game
where you know you can sustain and you
know really improve even in your 30s I
mean these guys are no spring chickens
anymore but still incredibly effective
so uh just something to note for all
these folks out there that you know are
like oh I don't know if I can improve on
my chest I'm too old these guys are
showing showing the way they're getting
older but they're getting better I saw
Hikaru played some 30 second chests
yesterday and acquitted himself
incredibly well so they still definitely
got the speed uh does sikara Nakamura
and eviel will have to show a lot of
speed today particularly in the bullet
because even if you beat Hikaru in the
first two segments he is capable of
making up what seems like an indefinite
number of points in that final half hour
let's take a look at our second page of
uh our Deloitte game analytics Hikaru
does have the much higher win percentage
47.7 as well as the more uh the higher
overall SEC experience but Casa these
are two of the most experienced SCC
players that we have
yeah no question and again mvl uh the
the rating disparity here between mvl
and Nakamura is not truly uh I think
it's like the gulf is a little bit
larger on paper than it'll be in this
match mvl is a incredibly worthy
opponent and
um he's just a beast in his own right so
for me uh I think it's going to be
closer than uh than our analytics might
suggest
I agree Casa I think mvl's form if he
can show the same form as he did against
nihal but this promise is to be an epic
match but we thought that about
yesterday's match between Carlson and so
you just never know how these SEC
matches go until you actually watch them
well one individual who thinks that they
know how the SEC match is going to go is
smarter chess and before the games begin
let's take a quick look at what smarter
chess thinks is going to happen in this
match smarter chess believes that it's
going to be relatively close but still a
pretty stable victory for Hikaru
Nakamura only a one point spread in the
bullet predicted and he thinks that mvl
is going to be good enough in the three
plus one portion
yeah I think the key for me is really
going to be how mvl starts in the five
plus one portion I think the key against
NACA in a lot of these matches is
essentially putting him under pressure
early so that it feels like he has to do
work late if it's even or you know knock
as an edge going to the bullet I think
he's gonna feel very good about himself
he definitely is I agree I think he
carves probably fine with the tied score
going into the bullet whatever happens
MPL has to avoid the Fate that met
Wesley so yesterday if you jump out and
and dig yourself into a three four point
deficit through the first 90 minutes
Magnus and Hikaru I think are the only
two players who can essentially
guarantee a situation where you won't be
able to come back as MBL makes his final
mental preparations for this epic
semi-final folks we are glad you're here
yakarnakamura and Maxima shiligrav are
about to take off in an incredible three
hours of action Casa this is amazing are
your seat belts fastened uh yeah let's
get this show on the road I just uh this
is just appointment viewing folks
appointment viewing
appointment viewing I like it and I just
love that we have courtside seats
obviously we'll determine a lot in the
first couple of games of this match
right what kinds of openings are we
going to see what kind of hikarnakamura
are we gonna see the one who plays one
A3 will he dare to do that against one
of the top opening players of all time
Casa something tells me we're going to
see more conventional opening choices
from Nakamura maybe one night F3 what do
you think yeah I'd suspect you know
Knight F3 B3 to feature quite a bit also
Knight F3 E3
um I think those pets pet systems of
knockoff seem to feature quite a bit
um I also wouldn't be surprised to see a
few anti-grunfels just to see uh oh
surprise surprise I think we have
something totally different
yes Knight C3 I've heard this referred
to as the van Geet opening and this is
the kind of opening console that often
transposes by force into a different
opening so I think chess players and
chess commentators say that it doesn't
have a lot of independent value like if
white takes on F6 and plays D4 then
we're just gonna get a Karo Khan uh
tardukauer structure yeah it's funny
yeah we basically have transposed to
karakan I always thought that D4 maybe
be a little bit more challenging than D
takes E4 now after Knight G3 H5 does
feature and uh quite a bit of these
positions if they're the retreat's a bit
premature I'm surprised not gonna go for
that tartic hour structure but
um yeah we'll see what happens here uh
otherwise uh maybe maybe he might
consider putting the bishop on the long
diagonal but okay he goes for C5 so my
question is where's that light squared
Bishop gonna go on C8
yeah that's a great question well I'll
tell you not F5 uh maybe he'll he'll
bring it out to G4 and try to provoke
some sort of weakening F3 move now
compared to the Karo Khan we've kind of
deviated right in the Carl Black would
have had a Pawn on C6 and white would
have had a Pawn on D4 mvl trying to
exploit uh the situation by bringing his
Pawn to C5 in one Fell Swoop and kind of
making it difficult for white to
liberate himself in the center
eventually I think MBO will continue to
clamp down on this D4 square with Knight
C6 and potentially even a trade on F3
yeah and unsurprisingly to me mvl opts
for sort of a groomfeld style setup by
fianchettering is a dark squid bishop
and yeah I think he's already equalized
um yeah
has basically warded off White's Pawn
break with D4
um you know so I think he could be quite
pleased with the early developments and
already we potentially have some Knight
takes E2 ideas although to be honest I
think White's control of E5 is what this
position essentially is going to revolve
around rather than the bishop pair in
this instance even though I do have that
that bias Donya
no I agree I think if Hikaru keeps the
tension with a move like rookie one
which he doesn't mvl might have kept
that night on T4 instead we have a bit
of a transformation a trade on D4 Maxime
brings his Queen out to B6 obviously has
to make sure that this Pawn is well
supervised he could play E7 E5
but Hikaru trying to prevent that and
keep this Pawn as an eminently
attackable Target yeah I think basically
what's going to come down to is whether
the C2 Pawn is more of a Target or the
D4 Pawn is more of a Target I recognize
E7 is hanging and I anticipate that'll
be covered but essentially black has
this half open file in the C file and
when we see I was going to even suggest
if the Queen ever leaves B6 uh leaves
the protection of that Bishop 186 we
might have a rook takes C6 sighting so
stay tuned for that
okasa you're the uh exchange sacrifice
master and I complete that is not a
far-fetched reality Rook takes C6 would
shatter completely shatter Black's
kingside Pawn structure it would offer
white Targets on the e-file so I
actually think this B6 square is you
know Prime real estate it's like views
of Central Park for the black queen now
though the Knight is swinging around to
F4 and mvl might actually want to
sacrifice that E7 Pawn because Casa
allowing Knight takes E6 is out of the
question I think we're gonna see Bishop
F5 and I don't think it's possible to
take because of Queen to D6 forking the
knight in The Rook yeah really nasty
tactics there and again that C2 Pawn
does present as a Target in a few moves
so if the bishop doesn't go to F5 you'll
see Rook ACH shortly thereafter and
black starts to you know you know loosen
the screws a little bit on White's Queen
side
I think that's a great way to put it and
I think Hikaru might have overlooked
Rook takes C7 Queen D6 that's a critical
detail that means black Gardener is
himself a Tempo that he can use either
as you pointed out for Rook a seat or a
move like Queen to C7 is is also
threatened that Knight on F4 is I think
a lot more of a vulnerability uh than it
is a strength because it just doesn't
have access to any important squares in
the center it doesn't have any purchase
I think we might see something on the
DraStic Side by hikar maybe some sort of
C4 yeah excellent point and the thing is
you might say why not why won't white
just play something like D3 well
essentially then the C3 Pawn the C2 Pawn
will be backward the C3 Square will be
soft and you know again the nine F4 is
not ideally placed you might see you
know a re-maneuvering of like E2 to G3
but that takes time so black does indeed
have a slight Advantage here
yeah and it's hard for white to find a
move it's not like White's position is
fundamentally unsound but the presence
of this weakness on C2 and White's lack
of space and you know the fact that the
Knight on F4 uh lacks the protection of
a pawn all of those factors put together
make hikaru's position very difficult to
play in the early going now Casa we
commentated the Hikaru Fabi match and we
saw so many situations where Fabi had
this type of position a Time advantage
and then both of those things evaporate
in the span of a couple moves a big
question is whether mvl can keep his
foot on the gas pedal and so far he's
doing a great job of it have you just
seen this move G4 Jim takes F7 F5 wow
what a sequence essentially shattering
uh the king side Nakamura did to
essentially get rid of that Bishop with
Tempo and he's arguing here that maybe
the bishop pair will compensate in the
long run essentially black has the
short-term assets though which are safer
King and pressure on the Y uh kingside
essentially if the Queens come off the
board uh if we just imagine the Queen's
gone off the board white might start to
have some uh nice long-term prospects
but that reality that's far from a
reality here so very very dangerous
position very dodgy position honestly
924 looks eminent yeah I mean you're
you're absolutely right I think a lot of
newer players would play Rook be it
automatically and that's not Rook B8 is
not a terrible move but white could
bring the queen up and try to make that
Queen trade a reality after Knight G4
white also will play Queen F3 okay and
Bill goes for it I think what he was
calculating is Queen F3 Queen takes D2
and we've got a very messy position but
to me it looks like white gets the
shorter end of the stick because
obviously hikaru's King is much much
weaker than its counterpart and with
White's pieces kind of scattered
throughout the board that might come in
very very handy for black like a
well-timed check on G5 or maybe some
sort of Knight Sally to G4 things do
look very scary here for Nakamura yeah
and don't be surprised here if there's a
rook lift along the fifth rank Rook B5
to G5 might present itself uh in a short
order and essentially you're gonna have
some problems with this this King on the
open G line so really tough tough spot
for white and I'm wondering what the
best course of action is perhaps Queen
F3 any way and just kind of essentially
pressing onward is The Rook tape C7
looks extremely fishy and just probably
bad so
maybe dropping the bishop back to G2 it
all seems very far-fetched
he's also got 46 seconds and we don't
say this often but he carved down to
town two minutes on the clock uh in this
first game Queen F3 on the board now I'm
expecting mvl to re-establish material
equality with Queen takes D2 probably a
calm move like rookie two uh is the best
bet for white then the queen likely to
drop back to G5 with Chuck and then I
think that the situation might uh
stabilize a little bit and MBL might
make a bit of a slower move in that
resulting position doesn't seem lost to
me I think if white can make a couple
accurate moves and stabilize the
situation the game goes on Casa I think
you might be right I think MPL might be
leaning on Rook B5 here yeah I must say
I Quinn xd2 I felt gave white some
momentum with rookie two and so on so I
do like the idea of of playing this way
and not trying to grab the material back
uh there should be four it's being
indicated as a mistake but it's an
extremely natural move and here we go
Rook lift with Rook B5 and uh Rook H5
looks pretty nice here and how about the
other Rook coming into D5 and then to G5
mvl puts it on G5 I think he's setting
up a night jump to G4 and the situation
has gone from dubious to bad to
potentially losing now SC Caro decides
which way he's gonna go he's gonna make
a run for it but Knight G4 wins the game
yeah Knight takes H2 is brutal and when
do we see Hikaru a minute and a half
down on the clock never so this is never
very impressive start
and mvl's time management against nehal
was excellent they had their share of
time scrambles of course but by and
large Maxine kept that 30 45 second lead
on the clock and that came in so handy
in uh critical moments such as this one
okay the correct move appears to be
Knight takes H2
and once the White Queen moves away from
F3 Black's Queen can now dive into F4
setting up completely decisive threats
this one is a couple of accurate moves
away from
zero one yeah the prime after Knight F3
is it's just so hard to cover the D2
Square without entombing your own King
so something like Bishop C one's out of
the question and rookie two would allow
Rook G1 so just trauma on the board for
the white king here which is not going
to find shelter if white could get two
moves maybe you can entertain rook ae1
and king D1 yeah scary the other way but
mvl hopefully here is gonna recognize
that and essentially not allow that to
happen
and it the bishop on G7 might make an
appearance here I I like the look of
rookie five check and now Bishop H6
setting up the battery mvl drops back
okay takes on F2 Queen takes H2
beautiful tactics rookie rookie one and
now I think Rook H5 wins the queen The
Rook H5 traps the queen yeah and wins
the game and also it it also allows
Queen F3 if the Queen ever Darts Away so
yeah this is a bit much and okay yeah
what what a game what a game
what a start we have ourselves a match
folks
that was impressive and that was
impressive from a lot of different
perspectives now let's not overstate the
case this was game one and sometimes the
first couple of games you're you're
developing your match strategy you're
feeling your opponent out but let's put
all of that to the side super impressive
display by Maxime on the board and very
importantly Casa on the clock yeah no
question about it and here we have a
rosalimo uh an opening that we've seen
feature in several World Championship
matches most notably in uh uh Magnus
Carlson versus Fabiano caruana in 2018
or 19 if my dates are getting mixed up
anyway typically here white actually
shatters the structure of Bishop takes
C6 but instead mvl's electing to keep
the bishop on the board
um and this is an interesting position
because white has a little bit more
space and black typically has to try and
break out at some point uh with
something like F6 but
um yeah it's a white whites definitely
has the edge here
agreed I think black's ideas boil down
to two overall plans one involves you
know this nothing happens fast in this
position because the center is closed
but you can kind of surround the D4 Pawn
by bringing your Bishop out to G4 and
eliminating its only Defender the knight
from E8 is often brought uh first to C7
and then potentially to E6 the second
plan uh as you indicated involves the
kind of French like idea of F7 F6
chipping away at White's excellent
central control there you see mvl very
alertly moving his Rook to C1 not only
preventing C5 breaks but also taking the
sting out of Bishop Basics which was
threatened and now I would Casa bring
this Knight around to B3 I'm looking
over at that juicy Square on C5 and if
I'm Hikaru I'm striking with F6 and
developing King side play because you
might get crunched on the queen side
yeah this is uh really interesting
illustration again of short-term trumps
versus long-term trumps except typically
you'd say well black is the bishop pair
so the long-term term Dynamics are such
that would favor Black well actually in
this case the pawn structure matters a
little bit more at least presently so
black has to move really quickly to try
and get some counter play on The Queen
side and there are some positions where
black might not even over protect the C6
Pawn if he's able to get this initiative
on the king side so H3 is prophylaxis
against Bishop G4 and black might
actually play G5 at some point uh to try
and push through G4 although 96 tells me
that's probably not going to happen
well I'm still pretty partial to G5
because it opens up a pathway for the
queen to G6 and Hikaru one of his many
great strengths is his ability to not
take things sitting down he senses so
well the moment when his opponent uh is
developing an initiative when the game
is starting to get out of control and
that is precisely the moment when he
poses the most serious problems I think
with the move G5 he indicates that no
I'm not just gonna let you run circles
over me and pick up the C6 Pawn you're
gonna have to pay attention to the other
side of the board and your point is well
taken Queen G6 might be a move to
consider even if at some point you're
sacrificing the C6 Pawn I would probably
start by pushing the h-spawn up and
preparing to smash open the king side
with the G4 I'm also very very fond of
the placement of this Knight on E6 it's
kind of lording over the whole position
from the center yeah it's not quite a
Carlsbad night but the night is really
well centralized and again the C6 Pawn
should not probably not be over defended
because white has you know ample
opportunity with rook ac1 and Knight A5
to get at it it's all about Black's play
on the king side and it honestly you're
you're a king's Indian player Dania it
almost has that feature except it's an
open position
yeah but it's got the same Contours or
White's attacking a Target on the queen
side and black uses that Target to slow
down the attack but doesn't as you put
it over defend the target so if white
plays Rook C1 I would consider uh
playing Bishop D7 but then if white
plays Knight A5 at that point I probably
wouldn't defend that pawn again with
with Rook C8 so Bishop D7 is is a good
move in general Hikaru drops his Knight
back to d8 to open up the diagonal for
the bishop I think he's preparing G4 but
Casa something about this move maybe
just visually looks a little bit off
yeah essentially you know you're I
always like to say for folks that you
know are at home trying to figure out
how to get better at chess usually the
side that connects their Rooks first is
the side that wins the game and in many
cases has the advantage and playing 98
you're basically unconnecting your Rooks
or getting it further away from that
happening and so you see white has this
opportunity to jump on black before
black does because the coordination it
just isn't there so that's just wanted
to just think about when you're playing
your own games and it's why white has an
advantage here
on the other hand but let's change some
things it changed some things what do
you make of this move
yeah I think again black has to why this
be a little bit faster here and I think
queen queen D3 is probably an example of
unneeded prophylaxis so the queen was
essentially uh unprotected and the
bishop on E3 was pinned and so and maybe
there was some wariness of allowing G4
and then some Bishop takes G4 so he
tries to try to get out of those threats
but maybe it was better to press on on
the queen side in some way
but if I were to take the Devil's
Advocate position I think he car
actually is defending that C6 Pawn with
everything that he's got and he is
planning to meet Knight A5 with Bishop
D7 and that's why the principle of two
weaknesses exists which states that in
positions where you're targeting only
one weakness you need to create a second
one preferably on the other side of the
board to overextend your opponent that
is why a move like H4 is not out of the
question trying to carve out uh some
dark squares on the king side because
Hikaru does have the Firepower right now
to keep his C6 Pawn under lock and key
but if you were to create a second
weakness on the king's side then Black's
position might get overextended great
awareness I think by Maxime and G4 might
be met with this maneuver Knight H2
Knight F1 Knight G3 and that H5 Pawn is
weak yeah and the nine the Knight on F3
was the kind of problem piece for white
so redeploying that Knight to G3 makes a
ton of sense
um
also you carved out the F4 Square for
your bishop and so that's why you see
this Rook B7 move just as prophylaxis to
deal with this bishop F4 move which is
really enticing and you might have a
situation now yeah all of a sudden where
white can actually make some nice
inroads on the dark Square so Queen D2
and some lines repairs Bishop H6
and also prevents the march of the
f-pawn down to F4 you can stick your
Bishop on F4 but I wouldn't do it here I
definitely wouldn't do it here and allow
The Rook infiltration to E2 I think the
bishop is optimally placed on E3 but
you're right in some situations Bishop
to H6 trades off the dark scored Bishops
and softens up the king side dark
squares even further now don't forget
about the queen side right you might
want to throw in a move like Knight C5
Knight A5 he sticks it on C5 and now
Bishop F4 Bishop D6 maybe yeah there's
so many nice uh there's so much
potential now and again if black doesn't
get toward the white king and doesn't is
able to push through really there's not
a ton of counter play and so white has
managed to still have the queen side
Advantage just there for a little bit
later in the game and really's done a
great job of restricting the advances of
Black's pawns at least in a way that
disturbs White's King side so really
enticing position and ultimately I think
right now white needs to figure out what
they're gonna do with the F4 screen
because you could consider Bishop 4 in
some positions right but you can also
consider the Knight redeploying to F4
and it just puts massive pressure on the
black king side
I I think Hikaru has to sit for the time
being I think he literally might have to
go King H7 King back to G8 he's weighing
the pros and cons of that approach right
now and probably contemplating a more
Brazen move like F5 as he falls behind
on the clock for the second game in a
row maybe he's trying to choose how he's
gonna sit Queen F7 is his choice maybe
B4 A4 and B5 to open up the C file is an
option but that actually eradicates uh
one of Black's major weaknesses so that
would be a very committal way to
continue this might come down to a Time
scramble both players close I must say a
minute on the clock great call Casa I
was gonna wait on F5 to play Knight D3
because I I do feel like as soon as F5
happens if black goes for it you bury
the lights where Bishop wears now black
can actually exchange and basically
solve that problem so I'm not too keen
on 93 right here but okay now Knight F4
I would play immediately
yeah rookie at night before by the way
was an alternative going after the C6
Pawn but mvl uh insists on playing
positionally principled chess but the
what now question the what now question
becomes harder to answer when you fall
below a minute how many players have
asked that question when they think
they're better against Hikaru and then
fall off a cliff when they don't figure
out how to make progress there's that
pawn March you know something I would
honestly go for Knight takes G6 and
queen C2 and argue that the F5 square is
going to be such a chronic weakness in
the end game
um that you know it's gonna just be
really hard to contend and black would
probably have to recap take on C2
recapture the king and guard the F5
score with the King on G6 but that's
kind of what I'm looking at oh that's
gotta be music to mvl's ear is that five
on the board and now the bishop on G6 as
you put it is buried okay do you support
that Knight by bringing the other one to
E2 because black might at some point
play Knight E6 and you want to make sure
that you can replace one night with the
other if that happens whatever you do do
not allow black to break down White's
blockade 30 seconds for Maxine so many
enticing options not enough time to
figure all of them out what does he do
yeah it's a really good question I think
maybe A4 just keeping the tension trying
maybe even playing B5 which seems
counter-intuitive because you uh okay we
have Knight we have Knight G2 instead
but it seems counterintuitive to trade
away the weakness on on C6 but if you
get the open C line for your Rooks it
might actually be worth it
our first all-out time scramble of the
match is gonna happen in the second game
let's keep a close eye on whether mvl
can compete with Hikaru in these low
time situations the bishop brought back
to G7 B5 blasting through on the queen
side now the weakness is the D5 Pawn
casan that is a very hard Pawn to defend
Knight takes C6 and Knight takes Knight
F4 oh but he takes immediately he's
shocking shocking um the D5 Pawn was not
going anywhere nope but still this is a
huge Advantage for White and the Knight
can go back to F4 oh Rook C7 wins the
game yeah and Rook D1 Rook D1 and he's
gonna win two in a row
very clean very very clean at the end
there and um impressive stuff impressive
stuff
uh wow we have a two-point lead for mvo
who would have thought what a game Casa
and that was a completely different game
uh the The Arc of the game was different
it was uh a pretty decent opening for
Hikaru but mpl's showing such a keen
understanding of those rosalimo
structures and then carrying it forward
in a great positional display 20 seconds
on the clock but he seemed right at home
in that situation but let's turn back
because we do have Knight A3 uh when was
the first time you saw this this
variation Knight A3 and the Sicilian so
it's funny I think it was in a Blitz
game on the internet and I was just kind
of baffled by it but don't be so
confused by this move because in a lot
of positions where you play like one
strange looking move you follow it with
a lot of just excellent computer-ish
moves and so I would say that it
basically takes on the character of a C3
Sicilian now and the Knight is is making
a weird kind of deployment um around the
board but it will basically it basically
transposes to positions that have uh iqp
iqp Vibes which for later in the game
now hikar just made another inaccurate
move now he should have put the Knight
on C4 he was trying to extract the
bishop pair in return for the D6 Pawn
but now mvl has managed to win that pawn
back and get sort of an ideal Pawn
structure I think black is slightly
better uh right out of the opening again
I just wanted to point out the first
time I saw the 293 variation was in a
new and chess article uh it was
pioneered by this Russian Grandmaster
who's most of the chat wouldn't have
heard of him do you know
very good vadim's wagensov yeah uh who
was high 2600 so to speak and you know
he was one of those Richard report-like
players of the early 2000s he he played
a lot of the sort of offbeat lines but
he was in OG and there's a famous photo
of zwagons of playing uh Alexander
khalifman uh and khalifman is uh he
cannot stop laughing and he's literally
sitting at the board in a classical game
and he's covering his mouth because you
know they're in a serious playing haul
but Vegas have just played Knight A3
three and back then this was such an
unusual move that uh Alexander is like
typical Vadim
yeah and it's funny Zack and stuff is an
extremely creative player and so
um he had he had more than just the
Knight A3 invention back in the day for
sure but this is a very interesting
position we have on the board here
because both Bishops on F1 f8
respectively have a little bit of a
tricky decision uh to make where they
should develop or not because the G2 and
G7 pawns are hanging so we see white
actually passed along to deal with that
and here we go it really looks
a bit like a French structure yes
um and the question essentially is
does white have enough here and my
answer is just no because uh black has a
very nice Bishop on C6 and I think it's
superior to the one on F1 and I think
for that reason uh Black's actually
slightly better
well it's like those movie scenes you
know where White's hanging on to a part
of the car but the car goes faster and
faster that Queen on G4 is is like the
person or like the zombie hanging onto
the car the only reason that black can't
complete his development and stand with
an excellent position is White's contact
with the G7 Pawn if black eliminates
that content uh content it like
eliminates that contact or Works around
it I think Hikaru might be in trouble
because of his King placement and
because black has the equivalent type of
situation as you pointed out Casa with
the bishop aiming at the G2 Pawn so now
I think he solved the problem Bishop E7
short Castle Hikaru has to waste a move
tucking his King back on C1 and he's got
another very difficult position yeah
massive Advantage uh they're really some
potential bowdoin's mate
yes
before Queen takes C3 and Bishop A3 mate
and I and queen C2 covers Bishop E4 but
again black is first to kind of jump on
white here and very very dangerous
position guys can I bring up an analysis
board just really quickly I I can't miss
an opportunity to show a bonus Made In
Action how could this have happened well
white could have dropped back to E1 and
after Bishop E4 white could have said
Hey listen the G2 Pawn is hanging let's
defend it with my queen and this is a
bonus made on steroids normally the D1
and do squares are covered by White's
pieces here they're covered by
blackstroke which is controlling the
open file this mate is named after
Samuel Bowden uh one of the top 19th
century players he pioneered this mate
and uh that is going to remain behind
the scenes Casa unfortunately as we go
back to
our live position what's not going to
remain behind the scenes is more
explosive play from Maxime and I think
when you're looking at this Vision
because both sides have Bishops you're
trying to figure out well what's the
difference and the difference is is the
Bishops on E3 and E2 first and foremost
aren't really hitting any Targets but
secondly they're also a bit loose the
bishman E3 is unprotected the bishman E2
is is covered by the C2 uh Queen but if
the e-line does open up and you see mvl
might have intentions of that right now
those Bishops will become targets and so
the combination of those two features
make it that black has a huge Edge
when you said the e-line open up I
thought you said the Elon opened up and
I thought you must have been spoken
um now we're gonna see Bishop G5
chiseling away at the dark squares mvl
is Like a Surgeon operating with these
squares after the trade cost of the
problem is that the Rook is diving into
D2 so in a way E4 was a thematic
positional sacrifice he's playing for
the squares here and he's playing for
Domination over the dark squares and
over the D file I think he's achieved it
and I think Hikaru walking on hot calls
now for the third game in a row yeah and
it's really impressive and it must be
said too that at some point this H4 Pawn
might chisel away and play H3 which
would also soften up that Bishop on F3
which is currently only defended by the
G2 Pawn so basically having full board
awareness is what we're seeing from mvl
right now and this infiltration is well
worth the pawn
it was a great Insight by you casa I
think we might even see H3 in this
position we might see it after the queen
lands on E3 of course black needs to be
very careful because the Rook is now
pinned to the queen and the queen is on
an undefended square but tactically I
don't think that white gets away with a
move like Rook to D1
um Queen E3 Rook D1 black and play uh
Bishop takes E4 check and then the G2
Pawn will fall uh When the Smoke Clears
I think mvl is deciding whether to throw
in the move H3 which I would or to start
with Queen E3 both are good options that
keep the advantage yeah I would
definitely Chuck an H3 and I think it's
just because the bishop on F3 is loose
that Rook you also if G takes H3 is
played you have access potentially to
that Rook on H1 because the bishop on C6
is staring it down and don't also uh
forget here that this King on G8 has
already has this Escape Square available
so there's no need to Tempo waste later
in the game whereas that B1 the king if
it might has to go to A1 something like
Queen E3 Queen E3 check there might be a
critical Tempo down the line that is
needed to be used and that could be the
difference
great points and H3 has been chucked in
by Maxime now Hikaru technically doesn't
have to take the pun but I think he kind
of does uh he might be briefly
calculating Rook D1 but then black has H
takes G2 and The Rook is Untouchable
because black will make a second lady on
G1 so we are going to see GH Queen E3
the one thing to point out uh is that in
some circumstances the bishop will be
Untouchable because the D2 Rook will
hang so GH Queen E3 I think ikara might
have to go Rook to E1 rather than Rook
to D1
but he's definitely hanging by a thread
Maxi might deliver that check on D3 and
start helping himself to White's uh
Sitting Ducks there on the H file yeah
this is a really really challenging
position to play from a practical
perspective
um just because their targets Galore
here and you might say well white is two
pawns up but it's the quality of those
pawns uh I said this last time Dania and
I'll say it again pawns are like kids on
a field trip on a school trip they have
to hold hands in the public places or
bad things happen and you see the H2
Pawn is weak the H3 Pawn is weak the E4
Pawn is also a potential Target
that you cannot say the same for black
spawns unfortunately you know it would
be very nice if they could hold hands
with E4 to G2 but they're all alone
there are no chaperones and I think bad
things are beginning to happen he's now
only one Pawn up and that material
advantage will slink back to zero uh I
think after Rook takes H3 or Bishop
takes E4 inevitably Hikaru is going to
lose at least one more pawn and as you
said black has managed to maintain uh
his domination over key Avenues and
boulevards in the position the second
rank the D file he's arranged his heavy
pieces perfectly and he's managed his
time perfectly as well as Hikaru once
again down to 30 seconds on the clock
with a Monumental defensive task ahead
of him we're used to him doing this
perfectly but will he drop his third
game in a row and again the back rank
problems I mentioned this before this
King now having had to Scurry to A1 to
get out the check will be a problem at
some point and so that Tempo might be
the difference between winning and
losing
absolutely and right now Maxime has to
decide where he brings his Queen back he
could bring it back all the way to d8
Queen D6 might run into E5 so big
decision here not a lot of time to make
it Rook C2 what a move
and keeping the pressure on I love this
but Queen B1 Hikaru stays on alert I
think we're gonna see we're going to F2
or F2 yeah H2 you called it
I think F2 was better Dania because he
had Rook F1 ideas too
see cars starting to reposition now as
he guards his H3 Pawn that Bishop is now
well positioned is mvl starting to lose
the thread slightly does he need to add
more fuel to the fire by running his a
pawn up the board
yeah maybe maybe he also can try
harassing that Rook on H3 with something
like Queen B6 or queen C5 but adjusting
course with Rook F2 is not basically
acknowledging that Rook H2 was
problematic but now you're allowing
white to consolidate yeah that Tempo
that he gave Hikaru was really really
useful because now the bishop is no
longer a concern and Hikaru playing for
the initiative threatening Queen d8 and
queen H4
such an alert alert Choice oh takes on
D4 takes on e4 and now it's a bad end
game for Nakamura terrible and the
backwink back rank weakness that was
need to be solved with B3 now that now
it's actually easily for white to
provide to improve their King and Target
these weak pawns again
rookie two Rook D2 picks up the D4 Pawn
eliminates counter play Black is now
completely winning in this end game he
cars only chances the clock but with
that one second increment I don't think
vaccine is going to have any trouble
converting this end game King F6 just
move the king there we go
look at White's King Hikaru has to play
rookie two beg black to take the D4 Pawn
just to get his King into the game but
the king is still cut off along the D
file
F4 push it yeah
salt and pepper F3 was possible there
yeah but understandable King D4
yep dance on the dark squares E3 F2 and
oh Naka flat when do we see that
while he was dead lost and when do we
see Hikaru losing three games in a row
to start not an SCC match any match at
any point in history in time Maxime is a
monster and he could not have asked for
a better start to this match and they
are repeating the rosalimo line so I'm
curious to see what is going to change
thus far nothing okay 98 Knight C7 we
saw that something similar before we saw
H3 to stop Bishop G4 but this is all
very similar to the previous game so
where is the the Nuance gonna come in
here I think Hikaru felt that he had
good practical play on the king side at
some point he mismanaged uh that
initiative maybe that moved remember
when he played 96 back to d8 uh maybe
he'll want to defend that pawn uh in a
different way but at first it's Maxime
uh who tries to figure out whether maybe
I want to take on F6 this time maybe I
want to arrange my pieces differently
but he ultimately resorts to H3 now so
let me make one thing very clear it is
only a question of time before Hikaru
gets on the board he's not going to lose
every game in this match and he's not
sitting there thinking oh my gosh this
is over he's got 56 minutes in the first
segment alone we know what Hikaru is
capable of and I don't think mvl is you
know opening the Dom Perignon just yet
yeah I mean let's be real this is
basically the equivalent of the first
quarter of a basketball game it's still
very very early days although we see
here before the night went to E6 block
that Bishop I I was a little bit
surprised about that now he insists on
G4 earlier gets the bishop to uh gets
the bishop that square and you can see
the counter play is a little bit faster
than it was before now the Knight might
come in afterward and uh and maybe try
and add some more pressure to the F3
Knight but that C6 Pawn is a goner
you're not gonna defend it and I think
that's the right way to play you're not
going to defend it Hikaru is not even
thinking about the move Bishop D7 here
in a in a Soviet chess camp that move
would have gotten you kicked out
immediately like you cannot give up such
to win the attack Rook d8 maybe and then
Knight E6 don't forget about the d-pawn
which is now Casa a passer and even
though it's the middle game that pawn
can Lurch forward and potentially even
trap the bishop on E3 yeah and there's
also ideas of you know the Queen the
black queen again coming to Jesus coming
to H5 adding more pressure to that F3
Knight so the Practical chances for that
that pawn that you give up are actually
quite decent you have the bishop pair
you have open lines you can even maybe
entertain doubling a Rooks on the f file
so I think it's going to be important
for the White Queen on E2 to kind of get
out of there sooner rather than later
of the positions that Hikaru has had
thus far in this match this is game four
uh if you're just joining us this is the
second semi-final to determine who
challenges Carlson on Friday in the SEC
final Maxime winning the first three
games in a row in sparkling style Hikaru
trying to find his footing of all of the
positions he sat out of the opening this
is the best one yet I think he has the
most serious chances that he's had and I
think he knows that and he's trying to
find the correct arrangement of pieces
so 96 and Rook d8 when does he involve
the queen a lot of questions to answer
here for black and where does he involve
the queen to H5 or to G6
yeah again black will probably have the
short-term trumps here as far as the
initiative on the white king white might
have some of the long-term Dynamics with
the outside passers although black also
has two Bishops and here we go Queen H5
adding more fuel to the fire in the F3
Knight
um but
our our computer here our silicon friend
is indicating this is a mistake I think
it's a very very uh reasonable move
it's a completely reasonable move now D4
is a huge Threat by the way black had
gone D4 on the previous move I think
there were some sort of tactics with
Queen C4 setting up a lateral attack on
the bishop so apart from everything else
this move does it actually does lend a
Defender to the bishop threatening D4
now white would love to open up a
retreating Square for the bishop but you
can't do that Knight B3 runs into the
simple uh Rook takes F3 so you need a
counter-attacking move what do you
counter attack well I think the Knight
is the only vulnerable Target in Black's
position and queen A6 is the only move
that keeps the foot on on the gas pedal
what a difficult find that would be yeah
it's funny I was already kind of
Desperately Seeking out exchange
sacrifices because if you give me a
speed found this wow if you give me a
few moves I would be perfectly happy to
have some combination of Rook take C6
and then the D9 come to D4 but there's
no time for that okay Knight F4 wow
okay this is a very scary looking uh
initiative here Knight takes G2 might be
an idea coin H3 check practically
speaking I still like Black's position
so there must be a very exacting play
here
yeah exacting play over the course of
several moves he he solved the first
problem he's jumped the first hurdle
successfully that was Finding Queen A6
now he's eliminated the Knight but
Black's pieces continue to stream in you
talked about the exchange sacrifice on
F3 there's like hanging pieces all over
the board right now the Rooks are
connected but the moment they become
disjointed you've got to watch out for
Forks this is the second hurdle and he's
crossed that successfully as well great
move by Maxime hitting the rook and
hitting the pawn yeah
after The Rook moves uh from a80 I
probably Rook a f8 uh the question is
this E7 really uh upon you can actually
take and
um that's a tough question to answer
I actually think you should play rookie
eight if you're a Hikaru and try to slow
down White's initiative on the queen
side I do think that white could grab
that pawn after rook f8 and the point
isn't to you know build up the material
advantage as much as it is to involve
the queen more directly in the counter
attack so I would grab this Pawn right
now otherwise why are you playing Queen
B7 yeah and I think the dynamic is
there's potential to go for Queen G5 a
little bit later not not in the moment
because E5 would be hanging F2 and be
hanging but there is a potential Queen
trade down the line and also black ever
chisels away and F3 with the bishop on
G4 or even the Rooks the C8 Square will
be vacant and you'll have this Rook C8
uh check idea which would really trade a
lot of the pieces and get close to that
end game that you're looking for it's so
easy to get cold feet when you're
playing Hikaru and he sacrifices a pawn
but mvl stays on course Rook 4 F7 great
move now three here Queen A3 to
reinforce the Knight laterally
although you have to watch out for
tactics there with that exchange stock
and F3 coming with Tempo Queen before is
possible Queen C5 how do you decide
where to bring the queen back Queen D6
is his choice and will we see will we
see that exchange sacrifice on F3
yeah I think the problem is even if that
exchange sacrifice happens there won't
be enough fuel on the fire to truly
deliver any mating ideas so it seems
more like a a potential Perpetual
opportunity but
um we'll see we'll see it's still
practically extremely scary uh to go
down this path even allow this exchange
sex so mvl is uh you know been very very
cool and calm thus far
I feel like black is running out of
options though because what what is
White's actual threat well white wants
to play E6 and run the spawn down to E7
maybe you could say E6 black has Rook F6
I don't think Hikaru is gonna dilly
dally any longer I think he's going for
it and he does and this is going to be a
fascinating denum all to this game Queen
takes F3 it's gonna hit the F2 Pawn
Black's King relatively speaking very
safe for the time being it could tuck
itself on h8 so the check on E6 is a
paper tiger I think mvl should just go
Rook C2 and acquiesce to the draw I I
don't see him playing with fire I don't
even know how he can play with fire here
yeah to me the question is do you throw
in Queen E6 check first just to cover
the G4 Square I think that might be
something you'd consider
um but yeah some combination of
Defending F2 and hopefully getting in uh
Rook C8 seems to be the the way to the
way to do it but
really really tricky position here
yeah the safest might be Rook one C2 and
then black has Perpetual check with
Queen D1 and queen G4 he does throw in
that check which tells me he's maybe
still flirting with playing for a win
but black and force Perpetual here black
doesn't even need the G4 Square uh to
deliver Perpetual you've got D1 and
you've got F3 but will we see a move
like Rook G8 from Hikaru Nakamura
intending Rook C8 and Bishop f8 oh my
goodness
this is getting really scary after Rook
G8 I think MBL might have overlooked
that move yeah Bishop f8 blocking the
trade with a discovery check is a move
that was difficult to see from before
and I think mvl just slightly reacted on
camera
he missed
and Rook C8 was what he relied on from a
distance forgetting that the bishop can
slice off the connection between the
Rooks that would lead to a loss of
material apparently you have to find
Rook to see straight and he did and he
did wow and The Rook will cover a
discover check on G3 forcing a Perpetual
check you can play King G2 or King H2
either works but King G2 is more clear
and Bishop f8 check in that position
would have resulted in Queen takes G8
check and Rook takes F3 and that was the
key detail there uh temporarily sacking
your queen uh to just win win material
in the game and so what a find
Exquisite accuracy by Maxime that's got
to come as a disappointment to Hikaru
and this is going to be a Perpetual
check
still a great game still relatively the
best position hikar has had out of the
opening but still I think a good result
for Maxime who keeps his three-point
lead yeah clutch stuff really clutch
stuff and
wow Dania thus far it's just been an
incredible level from nvl um really has
not really found himself in uh any crazy
danger and has taken the chances he's
had which is really hard against Hikaru
incredible level and and on many fronts
right not just in terms of his opening
play we expected Excellence on that
front but also his time management and
this pass game was the first time he had
30 seconds and a bunch of complicated
moves to find
and he found them and that I think bodes
very well in the early going that's a
very auspicious sign uh for his
performance in the subsequent segments
because let's not forget we are merely
observing the first of three segments
the three plus one and the bullet is
where the bread is often buttered for
Hikaru and here we go we have the setup
I thought the match would start with
which is this Knight of three B3 Knight
F3 E3 setups these setups that you can
play really really quickly and fluidly
and get very interesting Dynamic
positions
um okay here we have a really really uh
interesting structure with the Double C
pawns and a lot of times it comes down
to whether black uh can basically deal
with those weaknesses and get an
initiative of their own on the king side
whereas white typically has the
long-term play with a combination of
Knight A4 and Rook C1 and so on so black
has to make something happen in the
middle game to really justify the the
weaknesses on on the the C file
the Keen Observer will note that this uh
resembles a samish nimso Indian with
colors reversed if we could pull up an
announcement just to show people uh the
relationship between seemingly unrelated
openings after D4 Knight F6 C4 E6 uh
Knight C3 Bishop B4 the same ish goes F3
and we get in many cases the same
structure black takes on C3 and then
pushes D6 then white responds with E4
and you get this exact structure Casa
with colors or burst always important as
a as a keen Observer to note these
similarities between you could because
you can borrow ideas from an opening you
know and apply it to a position that you
might not know but to a structure that's
still familiar to you yeah and it's also
really important to know your personnel
um mvl is someone that does not play
these structures at least uh In
classical chess really ever and so
um you know Nakamura might also be
banking on that but I think thus far mvl
is handling things nicely uh tactically
speaking whoa castling long in this
position is certainly unique although
the king is relatively secure uh but
it's an unusual way to handle the
structure
yep I'm going to pull a Danny wrench and
lay on a an emote on the king that is
the first time I've ever done that now I
think upon closer inspection Castle's
Queen side is not as outlandish as it
may appear White's got this incredibly
solid Pawn triangle on the on the queen
side Casa that's very hard to break down
and look at Hikaru orchestrating play on
the other side of the board H4 is an
excellent move yeah and essentially what
this position boils down to even with
this H4 move is the C pawns and
particular the C5 Pawn what happens in
this structure is white is constantly
going to be entertaining uh tickling
that pawn putting pressure on it with
moves like Rook C1 and so on but also by
try to divert Black's attention from
that C5 Pawn by putting pressure on the
E5 pawn and on the king side so H4
entertains H5 but also potentially
removes this defender of the E5 Pawn uh
that Knight on G6 so there might be
pressure against E5 with something like
Bishop B2 or queen B2 at some point and
so it's basically tickling the C5 25
pawns uh long enough that black gets
frustrated and something drops and
that's essentially what NACA is trying
to do here and is this the first
Advantage that he's had in the match
thus far
oh man that is wild to say that is
insane I know
it really is but he does he has an
advantage here I think on both sides of
the board Rook to see one is an
understandable move he is threatening C
takes D5 and he is essentially I
wouldn't say compelling but provoking
Maxime into closing up the center with
D4 then he might want to switch his
attention over to the e-file so he drove
that pawn down to H6 to provoke
long-term weaknesses on the king side
now he is Shifting his attention uh to
the other two sides of the board where I
think he also holds an advantage and the
clock situation this is what we're used
to from Hikaru Nakamura yeah and it's a
really interesting position because
you're trying to figure out how to
improve with black I don't like 970
because it cuts off the defense of the
G7 Square so move like Queen B2 at some
point seems compelling to me
um uh because the e-pawn can't move and
the nine F7 can't move because there's
Knight takes E5 and again the seat the
C4 pawns and the D5 pawns that are
connecting here I describe this as a
positive Pawn intention for white white
essentially can take whenever they want
and is going to wait for the opportune
moment to do so and it's not an ideal
Pawn tension for black because
essentially if you do capture on the C4
you give uh you you give black uh you
give white essentially this target so
interesting decision he essentially
allows the C5 Pawn to be captured and
it's banking on counter play on the C
file I I was gonna ask you know can we
eat of the Forbidden of the Forbidden
tree why can't we take on C5 now this
looks scarier than it is because after
Bishop C5 Knight C5 there is a pin
against the Knight but white could
always support whatever piece is on C5
with the move d4 now he has Bishop takes
D6 which is a nice Escape Route that
gives him the tempo he needs to probably
Knight C5 or even Knight back to C3 to
hit D5 do not move your queen to B2
because black snaps the Knight off the
board and seriously weakens White's King
yeah if if you can stab publisher Nancy
five and then reinforce it with D4
you're gonna carve out excellent dark
squares on C5 and E5 and again don't
forget the spawn H6 covering the G7
Square there might be a sighting later
in the game so uh essentially that's
what naka's trying to figure out is
whether he can establish that dark
Square Bond otherwise he will go Knight
C3
for sure Knight C5 Knight C3 these are
the two candidate moves and he's managed
his time well he's got uh the time he
needs to make an informed decision it's
so important to look at the position
concretely I think newer players would
be really scared of playing the move
Knight C3 because it looks like black is
on the cusp of being able to play D4 but
look at how concretely these players
approach every position Knight C3 guess
what the D4 square is defended more
times than it's attacked therefore this
move is safe to play because on the next
move if he is so inclined he can move
the queen away from C2 and then you
never have to worry about a pin again
yeah and again if black black really has
to act quite quickly to try and disrupt
this because if white establishes this
dark Square grip with Queen B2 uh with
some pressure on E5 it's gonna be scary
hours so uh really really difficult uh
decision time for MPL because yeah this
is the the toughest Mission he's he's
had thus far in the match
I think he's losing you know it's one of
those things the more I look at it the
the worse it looks it's like airplane
food you know this isn't that isn't that
bad and then you smell those smells and
you actually look at it you're like wait
no this is really bad uh he's under a
minute why is this so bad well he's down
upon and I think D4 indicates his level
of desperation trying uh it's a stir up
complications on the queen side I think
he might want Knight B5 but then the
queen can calmly drop away to B2
I I honestly don't see it Knight takes
D4 there goes the second Pawn okay so
Maxime is targeting whitesnites his best
chance is to engineer some sort of
pressure down the save file but Knight
D2 E2 Casa reinforces this Knight a
third time right and you're going to see
Queen B2 down the line if allowed if the
Queens come off the board all the end
games now are extremely advantageous
um so you know and queen B2 basically
will force a trade of a queen so here we
go but this is a very devious move by
Maxine because Knight takes B5 right now
blunders a piece to Queen takes B2 and
then Rogue takes E2 check and then the
other night uh will be picked up by the
bishop so Maxime hanging on here with an
excellent practical move Hikaru might
want to push A4 and kick this Knight
away from B5 that might give him the the
real estate and the breathing room that
he needs uh to coordinate his pieces
instead we see Rook C2 reinforcing the
idea of Knight takes B5 yeah I must say
that was that was going to be my choice
Rook C2 just you know like a little bit
of a little bit more prophylaxis you can
entertain Rook hc1 down the line
um and yeah Knight takes C3 here I don't
see any any major problems with it uh
with 95 to follow
yeah I mean you could oops sorry he
didn't do that yet you could take with a
rook if you are so inclined
um trying to get another pair of Rooks
off the board
but either way either way I think
White's position is technically winning
although after Knight takes C3 maybe
bishop C6 will be played just to kind of
disrupt the 1995 idea and you know you
take you take a gander G2 and oh here we
go um it's a nice practical attempt but
again there's no way to really you know
deter from the queen trade which
inevitably it will transition it to a
completely winning end game because that
H6 Pawn just a thorn in the side even if
there aren't checkmating ideas a thorn
in the side is the perfect way to put it
and even in an endgame it's annoying
because it creates a stronghold
potentially for white truck it's also
very hard to attack that pawn even
hypothetically you literally can it's
inaccessible uh to Black Strokes it's
inaccessible to Black's King and I think
now is the perfect opportunity to move
this Knight away from C3 maybe to A4 or
even back to D1 and force the queen
trade because black cannot allow a queen
to land on G7 that would be Checkmate
once the Queen's come off the board The
Rook on C2 will also potentially have
its say with the Rook C7 down the line
the only problem piece here for white
I'd say would be the H1 rook and you'll
feel a lot better about you know mosing
mosing that into the position once the
Queens come off so I think Knight A4 is
a really Sound Decision getting a temp
on the bishop here and yeah Rook C7
looks very nice Rook D7 I think is
absolutely well rookie two last-ditch
attempt but with 20 seconds left not
over yet I would throw in a check on G7
and then think he doubles on the seat
file as you put it the Rook mosing over
or dancing over to the C file will we
get Piggies on the seventh no we won't
mvl prevents that from happening maybe a
trade and the other one comes into C7 in
a classic yeah and this doesn't uh
lessen the damage at all now you're the
Chuck and Rook G7 just to tuck the king
to the corner and then you go Rook A7
and threaten me oh or rookie seven even
well rookie one rookie one though
careful
oh my gosh she had rookie one and Bishop
takes B3
oh he missed it oh
and Hikaru would have had to block with
his Knight he was still winning there
still winning with King B2 or King C2
but yeah okay now he's gonna win for
sure
and 95.
and Maxime is going to let his time run
out and Hikaru chipping away at this
three-point lead kind of incredulous
that it took him five games to win his
first game but that was excellent that
was a big confidence boost Casa it was
hikaru's first Victory but also a wire
to wire victory yeah you wouldn't uh
believe it by the look on nakamura's
face at the end there he's shaking his
head so vigorously but it is an
important game and he is kind of finding
his form now and so we'll see how things
progress but this is not a huge lead uh
there's a lot of games to go so
it's not a huge late and there is a huge
amount of time remaining folks the score
in our second semi-final is three and a
half one and a half Maxine winning the
first three games of the match and we
will be back folks with more speed Chess
Championship action presented by
coinbase first we're gonna take a short
break see you in a bit
foreign
[Music]
I'm Andrea and I'm Alex and we've been
playing competitive chess since we were
six years old
[Music]
I started by focusing on classical chess
but later we fell in love with playing
Blitz and bullet online
[Music]
this has been around for more than one
thousand years but that doesn't mean
that we can't modernize it Financial
systems have been around for even longer
sounds like it's time for an update and
coinbase is doing just that
re-envisioning an entirely new Financial
system that is decentralized and fully
transparent
also huge thank you to coinbase for
sponsoring competitive chess and making
events like the SCC happen go to
coinbase.com update the system to learn
more
September Bots are here and it's time
for a Monumental Clash
this Barbarian might not Crush you on
the board but he certainly can Crush you
with the board
speaking of crushing this giant is a
living Siege Tower usually found in
groups goblins are fond of sharp pointy
objects and other people's pieces
the battleheart in Valkyrie might give
you a game once she's done arm wrestling
a Golem
this hog rider and his Noble Steed might
give you a headache or two skeletons
adore her those fear her you'll need to
bring your A-game if you want to be this
witch yes that probably is a rabbit up
his sleeve or a huge Fireball with your
name on it we hear Wizards are pretty
good at chess
not just a killing machine Pekka loves
tiny butterflies but you're probably not
a butterfly so watch out
the Archer Queen thinks highly of
herself and for good reason she is a
skilled tactician deadly opponent and
your worst nightmare
lay them all on chess.com
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
chess and he is certainly no stranger to
Elite performances in the speed Chess
Championship which he's had quite a few
of he leads this second semi-final over
Hikaru Nakamura with a score of three
and a half or one and a half as we
prepare to begin the second half of the
five plus one portion and we take a look
at mvl's storied run in 2020 where he
was stopped by hikarnak Nakamura in the
final Casa but not before he put in a
series of exciting and very impressive
performances
yeah no question about it um this is a
guy who is just incredible chess player
like he uh really is quite flexible
um and and basically puts a lot of
challenges with the white pieces with
the black pieces we've seen him kind of
basically expand his repertoire quite a
bit in recent years and uh you know he's
shown great uh fluidity in the matchup
so far
he really has he won the first three
games in a row then they had a draw in
that rosalimo and Hikaru finally strikes
in game five with a very smooth Victory
I like tikara's opening Choice from the
white side but right now it's mvl who
has the white pieces and we are getting
an early storyline a battle in the
rosalimo sicaro deviates from G6 and
decides on a less common move D6 yeah
this D6 move is a really interesting one
typically here you don't see white
capture on C6 so quickly because uh you
know black has actually hasn't really
committed
um to G6 so and these types of
structures you'll usually see the bishop
drop back to F1 and then white will
typically press four with C3 and D4
which is actually not too uh too
dissimilar to the dynamic we've seen in
the games where mvl had been playing C3
and D4 without capturing on C6 right
away so interesting
and this is the main line with the
bishop coming to G4 and usually usually
exchanging itself for the Knight because
if the bishop drops back to H5
oftentimes white does push G4 Casa and
then quickly strikes at the center with
D4 and then you get some sort of
inferior open Sicilian structure so
Hikaru does trade on F3 and now the
position turns from Dynamic to largely
positional as both sides complete their
development yeah and what do you see
here with white typically you see the
queen drop back to D1 the Knight on B1
goes from to F3 it goes Knight D2 Knight
F3 and then you typically see white
slowly prepare for this D4 push and
argue that the bishop pair once D4
happens will give white a slight
Advantage black deters that by
establishing a dark Square grip on the
D4 and E5 Square so you see the night
drive man to D7 the bishop G7 exerting
itself on the diagonal and B5 B4 in the
offing
yeah it is in the off thing and that is
another positive byproduct of the night
dropping back to D7 black increases his
control over the D4 Square I actually
had this exact position uh in a world
youth Chess Championship Game many years
ago and white strikes with D4 we get an
exchange on C3 and now black Targets
this newly isolated Pawn uh backward
Pawn I should say on C3 so White's big
ass biggest asset cost of the bishop
pair uh and the superior central control
Black's biggest asset is his enduring
play on The Queen side uh with the Rooks
potentially coming also to these C8 and
B8 squares and Rook C1 is such a such a
clever and interesting move because
essentially that A2 Pawn looks kind of
poisonous but I I I'm not quite sure
what the what the refutation is whether
it's okay one back or rookie but it
seems kind of poisonous it's like I I
know I'm not gonna take this spawn I
don't know exactly why I'm not gonna
take it but something about it feels
rotten and we do see Rook FCA but by he
he reserves the possibility of taking
the spawn and Casa Bishop C4 is a
tempting move but that Bishop is going
to be right in the middle of things and
it's going to be easily targetable by
the knights yeah that Bishop on F1 on F1
isn't going anywhere anytime soon I
think and ultimately it does look at the
A6 uh Pawn so it is exerting influence
even from far away the question for me
is what does white do with their Queen
because I would really like to connect
the Rooks but it's not so convenient uh
where you go if you make move like Queen
D2 uh black will actually release the
tension and probably go C takes D4 and
essentially converge on the D4 Square
because the bishop or the Knight would
have to recapture and whoa we do see in
Bishop C4 this is a bit of a surprise
for me
I'm very curious what his intent is
against Knight B6 well we're about to
find out I think it is Bishop B3 uh but
wait a second after C4 he is gonna drop
the c oh he's gonna drop a C3 Pawn but
then the B6 Knight will be targeted by a
well-timed D5 Pawn push so
um let's wait for his move I'm not I'm
not gonna ask for an analysis sport just
yet because Bishop B3 is not forced
there's even this weird move Bishop to
D5 trying to trade on his own terms
there is a sacrifice oh my God
seat belts fastened Queen B3
Queen B3 I think to start yeah Queen B3
in conjunction with Knight G5 is really
awesome and note that C4 which naturally
just would block the that check the
bishop Bish money through be open to
capture on B6 so I think you might have
to go see forecast I think C4 might be
the most practical move because it does
force the queen trade and then they're
ensuing end game black is down a pawn
but but White's got this big Target on
C3 I think that was a very heads up
decision by Nakamura
yeah and I how do you handle this one
because again the long-term weakness
here on E6 is going to be problematic
Knight G5 check will be an issue so
um
wow this this is this is a quite a
dynamic position Queen takes me six
Bishop takes B6 I don't think black has
full compensation by any stretch I agree
and that is why Hikaru is taking a pause
here Bishop takes E3 as possible if we
could pull up an announcement really
cool I would just want to show for newer
players who might be thinking wait a
second why did he give this piece back
why didn't he bring his King back to f8
well this is part of a very thematic
idea white drives the Knight up to G5
and creates mate threats along the light
squares you can defend F7 with a move
like Knight T8 but now white plays this
very pretty sequence Knight H7 driving
the king further into the center and
picking up the bishop with absolutely
devastating uh effect and of course here
if you play Knight E5 well the same
exact fate away to Knight takes H7 and
queen G8 is the second thread and that
is why Hikaru decided to give back the
piece we go back to the live board and
in fact he did Casa you're correct
Hikaru didn't like that pawn down end
game and instead he takes on C3 mvl
keeps the tension and says you want to
trade now we'll trade now but then
you're gonna lose the C4 Pawn Yeah and
this is a really really a tricky
position the decision for knockout to
make here because
either way you're basically going to
essentially what I would contend would
be a two results game which is win for
white or Draw for white I don't think
they're any really serious chances
um for black here and just given the
mangled structure on the king side and
even on the even on the queen side of
the C4 Pawn being a Target really tough
to keep things together and that's why
naka's shaking his head because he's
like yeah I have a tough decision to
make well I think he has to take the
queen I do not see any reality where
black keeps the Queens on the board and
and survives this I think he's got to
bite the bullet trade Queens drop his
Bishop back and then at some point play
Knight C6 to E5 try to get control of
the C file and just hold that pawn down
position which we know how good Hikaru
is at doing uh but he's got to make sure
he's in the right frame of mind because
if you're frustrated then that increases
the chances that you make some sort of
impatient move and exacerbate uh the
already difficult situation yeah and as
the Queens potentially come off the
board uh maybe some other piece come off
the board you start to entertain some of
these Rook end games and so the one that
I'm entertaining based upon what you
just mentioned is these four versus
three Rook end games all on the same
side if you imagine the queen side pawns
are eliminated that four versus three is
a tricky hold because Black's pawns are
split typically if you're Pawn down in
these Rook end games with pawns on the
same side you can hold it with best play
but when you you have additional
weakness it's super challenging to hold
particularly with low time
yeah
I've had so many of those end games from
both sides I've had I feel like I've had
to defend so many three on fours against
particularly Russian GMS in the 26th
2650 range which is like the worst type
of flare to have to defend these Pawn
down end games against but that's part
of Chess you have to embrace the suck
here and I really like what Hikaru is
doing Knight to E5 is on the board get
the knights off but more importantly
seize control of the C file if you can
and make sure that your Rook is as
active as it can be yeah and we're
getting there um and I would not take on
C8 here yeah I like this move Rook A4 I
also liked Rook DC One really important
not to give black uh you know all of the
control particularly with that
money 5 controlling H2 why it's gonna
have to waste a Tempo to give themselves
a scape Square because uh the H2 square
is covered and so I like Rook A4 just
basically keeping some pieces on instead
of allowing all the trades and root
beans is such a precise move I'd say
very heads up response by Hikaru now the
pawn on A6 is not even in question Rook
C6 looks completely unappetizing mvl
will drop his Bishop back to E3 and any
car I think is going to work on
optimizing the activity of his Rooks and
yeah sacrificing a second Pawn on A6 we
talk about this all the time Casa most
important thing in the end game not
Material it's the activity of your
pieces particularly if you're on the
defensive I think we're going to see
rooksy too and Rook takes A6 I think
will be met with Rook to B4 targeting
the E4 Pawn yeah and it's really
important to essentially shake the tree
a little bit and so essentially by
attacking the four Pawn you're saying F3
is kind of out of the question because
then the you have access to the G2 pawn
and then the Rooks double and that's out
of the question so really really precise
here
um to go after the E Pawn instead of the
a pawn which is a essentially a more
valuable Pawn to take at this point and
you see finally G3 being played to solve
that escape Square issue but uh she
takes G3 might be a threat
it was a threat and mvl trying to kick
the Rook away from the second Rank and
simultaneously of course after the trade
uh you no longer have this undermining
move Bishop takes G3 Rook cc4 very
accurate now the threat of Bishop takes
G3 is renewed and look at how Hikaru
manages the defensive test he gets the
Rook to A4 blockading the pawn on its
initial square and reducing its
influence down to a minimum and now I
think he's basically just gonna sit by
putting his Bishop on a defended Square
getting his King to the center and he's
gonna politely or not so politely ask
Maxime sir how are you making progress
how are you ever going to get this Pawn
past A2 and this is truly a master class
in defending essentially you are a
clearly uh a pawn down you were
temporarily two pawns down and basically
making sure that White's Advantage was
kept to a minimum here was extremely
impressive now you see Black's King is
more active than White's King Black's
Rook is more active than white Black's
Bishop is more active than White's
bishop and that makes all the difference
when holding this
we take hikaru's defensive dexterity for
granted but it really shouldn't and it's
amazing how when he's upon down it's not
like oh you know he had to suffer for 80
moves and you know the advantage was
passed around it's like mvl had no
chances to begin with and he continues
to make perfect moves trades on G4
arranges his pawns perfectly and now I
think it's essentially time to sit okay
he pushes E4 now it's time to sit by
shuffling your bishop and making sure of
of course that the king is not able to
infiltrate G5 yeah and essentially it's
really hard for white to make any
progress at all the king can't enter via
the dark squares on F4 or H4 The Rook is
Tethered to the a pawn
um you know really it's hard to move any
of White's pawns or even activate any of
the pieces without dropping something
and so that's essentially why this is
probably going to be a draw
yeah and we're seeing some shuffling
here of course Maxim is not risking but
with the one second increment that is
ample time for Hikaru to deal with any
challenges as they arise I think we're
gonna get a repetition to move shortly
here Maxine's still trying but now the
material has been reduced to a minimum
and Rook A4 is coming and it's a draw
yeah and you might say well why is white
being so defensive why why was black the
one that was the aggressor being the
material down why was trying to maintain
the material advantage while uh while
you know playing this out and
essentially sometimes when you try to
maintain your material advantage you you
basically kind of consolidate and crawl
into a ball and it's kind of hard to be
aggressive and defend all the weaknesses
and so this almost symbolically here
this almost feels like a win as you can
see all of a sudden it's black I mean
what is what is mvl doing he could have
traded uh the Bishops there and just
secured the draw instead he's gonna
actually have to defend this now for a
while and the last thing that you want
is a situation where you have to give
your Bishop up for the pawn and defend
rook and Bishop versus Rook now that
should never happen here and white
should be able to hold but I've seen
Hikaru squeeze wins out of these types
of positions that's not an exaggeration
King G4
and you've got to be careful all of a
sudden Rook A2 yes this is a little
careless Bishop C5 no Bishop C5 what is
he doing oh my goodness through the game
he threw the game
he threw the game the pawn end game is
gonna be a win because Black's gonna get
the opposition can you believe this
no he was winning and he's now it's draw
again
oh my gosh don't worry everybody we will
rewind this and everybody else get a
flag no he's not
King takes G5
okay oh my gosh and now he's gonna have
to defend he's gonna have to defend Rook
Bishop versus Rook with no time this is
favorable for Naka now for sure I would
say in the time the time trouble
for newer players this is a theoretical
draw what does that mean that means this
end game has been studied as early as
the 18th century by philidor who thought
that it was winning for the side of the
bishop Howard Stanton came along in the
1840s and he was the first to declare
that this is a draw it is but it's
almost impossible to make it with only a
couple seconds on the clock so far so
good for Maxime but his King has been
driven to the corner of the board that's
where it is hardest to defend this
position yeah and when you have such
little time oh here we go oh he's lost
that's it yeah yeah
and maybe not Hikaru still has to find
the right sequence of Rook moves but I
think he's doing just that yeah a
well-timed rook h8
okay Rook A8 but how do you actually win
because Rook H3 is not mate
oh my gosh this is insane
yeah it is Rook G8 maybe Rook G8
threatens made on h8
oh
and it's a draw wow that's a repetition
any CaRu is incredulous
wow I mean gosh
I'm speechless I'm so speechless because
that there should not have happened at
all mvl got so careless we we have to go
to an analysis board here Casa sorry
just unbelievable
okay so let's let's go all the way but
forget the rook and Bishop end game
let's go back for a second to not this
position this position how on Earth if
you're Hikaru Nakamura do you not see
that this pawn and him is winning
because you get the opposition at the
end of it Casa and I'm not even going to
belabor the point this is a win now
importantly King G4 the pawn is on a
dark Square so you can guard it with
your Bishop this would have ended the
game
maybe this is what was missed but um
because I I've I think NACA would have
easily seen the opposition concept but
um just a shocking shocking development
we have a new game but honestly given
the way that second half of that game
went it kind of feels like a win for mvl
so
um just an unbelievable term events and
yet naka's not pleased and uh is really
trying to make something happen now
Knight G6 looking at Knight F4 do you go
G3 it's a it's a really risky decision
given that H5 H4 might happen in the
Kingston opposite side so Knight B3
would seem to be safer to me but Naka
goes for G3 and is saying Bring it on
Bring on H5 I'm not scaring it on Bring
It On Boy bring it on girl in F5 instead
by Maxime explosive in the center and of
course we have a classic scenario of
opposite side attacking now do you take
this Pawn back on C5 what is giving
Maxine pause is it the fact Casa that
white is going to bring the night out to
B3 and storm clouds are slowly but
surely going to start gathering around
Black's King yeah I actually think
Bishop C7 would be a decent practical
choice although objectively it's surely
not a good move I I find it hard to
believe that uh that Black's gonna be
able to defend this uh because it seems
like white is a little bit faster in the
in the queen side but here we go E5
closing the center and then mvl
insisting on opening somewhere with F4
uh and yeah the battle lines are drawn
I still can't believe what we just saw
in the previous game I'm still kind of
you know in that post game shock of like
holy crap what did what just happened
that malays exactly but the players I
mean imagine the frame of mind that
they're in after a game like that and
that is the fun of the SEC you start the
next game immediately the player who is
faster at adjusting emotionally and
mentally has the advantage and I feel
like that polarity car Nakamura despite
the fact that he missed the win he's
right back to attacking A5 this looks
terrible Knight C5 Queen B5 I mean mbo's
getting mated here yeah no question
about it and that's why Bishop takes C5
I think practically was the wrong choice
even though objectively it might not
have been so bad because white just got
so much momentum here and so Knight C5
in conjunction with uh Queen B5 or even
well time Rook B1 is gonna be a wrap
um and in addition to looking at the B7
Pawn the E6 Pawn is also extremely soft
so
it's really tough to make any reasonable
inroads on the king side for black in
time
black is dead after Queen B5 oh is he
gonna play Rook takes eight no way does
he have Rook takes a seven there oh yes
he does oh my gosh yeah
Bishop B6 Rook takes A7 and either way
you capture on A7 oh White's Queen's
gonna have an inroad to B6 or B7 just
disgusting removing the defender folks
such an important tactical Motif this is
Chuck mate and after Knight A7 you just
vacuum up a million pieces on the king
side uh Queen takes A7 technically it's
the queen side
um and this is gonna be game over and
guess what it's on the board what an
Exquisite attacking display by Hikaru
Nakamura three-point deficit what
three-point deficit says Hikaru
just s sparkling sparkling plan uh
really it's a question I think whether
mvl wants to get to another game quickly
and resign okay he does or run some
clock I think the decision just now was
made he wants more five plus one games
and that's a completely reasonable
choice I think Maxine thinks especially
after the way this match started that
this is the segment where he needs to
jump out to a lead and he did but I felt
a turnaround it seems like Anvil just
isn't as in control of these games as he
was
just a couple of games ago at the start
of the match
yeah and okay here we go we're back in
rosalimo land although we have D6 right
which was nakamura's change from the
last match we saw C3 and D4 prepared
earlier
um although this time around we have an
early age three preventing this bishop
takes F3 stuff that happened before kind
of surprising that mvl deviated given he
got such a fantastic position before but
this is all reasonable I've played this
on the black side Dania and when I I
actually played this against arientari
and he played an early age three and I
actually responded with uh Rook G8 and
G5 uh play against the hook and uh it
was a a nice position for me man Acosta
Rook G8 imagine the feeling when you
play a move like that over the button
you get and then you get up and you make
sure that you know the crowd is gathered
around the board when you play a move
like this I will admit to doing that
sometimes when I when I spot when I see
the win in an over the board game I'll
sometimes wait until the maximum number
of people have come up and then and then
you kind of slowly uh carry out the
moves there is a certain charm to over
the board play here we've got over 10
000 of you gathered across the platforms
big big shout out to everybody taking
time out of what I'm sure is a busy
Wednesday but hopefully you have been
handsomely rewarded with some
entertaining chess we most certainly
have been and mdl still leads by a point
E5 is a big decision by Hikaru yeah it
essentially transposes to rui Lopez
positions particular chagoran positions
because white typically shifts gears to
play C3 and D4 and here we go we have
that structure on the board not a lot of
black players play these structures
anymore
um the computer tends to look favorably
on them for white but
um it's always tricky to break down and
it's usually a long maneuvering game
where you know black tries to organize
something on the on the king side with
the F5 we might say G6 Knight G7 and
white tries to break through on the
queen side with the A4 B4
and black strikes first B7 B5 this type
of structure also occurs out of a Roy
Lopez and if black plays G6 and Knight
G7 also we get that King's Indian flavor
with F7 F5 I quite like this for black
from a practical standpoint but the
engine and such positions Casa always
assigns a big advantage to White yeah
it's funny too because I rarely see
black playing for B5 in the manner that
he did here so it's interesting that
he's kind of by playing energetically on
the queen side kind of staved off whites
uh aggression a little bit with this
move B3 which is just kind of
consolidate that side so that's actually
kind of interesting black is playing on
both sides here and F5 will be incoming
I don't understand why the engine always
seems to give plus one like that
evaluation it always plus one and then
it's like Bishop D2 Bishop C1 Bishop D2
like come on stockfish how my how myopic
can you be here there comes F5 and I
don't know about you casa but I would
almost prefer to be black here yeah I
think the part of the reason that uh
that the computer does give these
advantages is sometimes or a lot of
positions white actually just takes on
F5 and gives black these hanging pawns
and it seems like this nice poncho on E5
and F5 super flexible and can kind of
advance and do some stuff but in a lot
of positions it's actually hard to push
without creating a weakness so if black
plays F4 after the the enf pawns are
exchanged then the E4 squares in The
Outpost and sometimes E4 gives uh you
know white this F4 Square for a bishop
or a knight so it's always tough to
figure out what those hanging pawns how
to press onward but the Practical
chances being the half open G file and
even you know pressure on the king
usually is worth it I think it's so
instructive how Hikaru seems is playing
on both sides of the board but also the
way that his pieces are arranged he
doesn't have a single piece past the
seventh rank he's like a War General
commanding everything from his
comfortable headquarters by the
fireplace you know the Knight on Jesus
everything is on a nice inaccessible
defended square and the pawns are doing
the heavy lifting now you called it Casa
we get this hanging Pawn structure so
the typical prescription here is F4 but
in this particular instance I thought F4
might run into E4 and Bishop F6 I think
we are going to see the bishop land on
F6 and now the engine is finally on
board Hikaru is taking over this game
again yeah and what's the difference
here in my opinion the reason black
actually has the advantage in this
structure is because of the queen side
inroads the inroads black is made on the
queen side typically it's white that's
showing the aggression there black is
played on both fronts and so now you see
The Rook on V8 has the potential to
exert itself and if the bishop
recaptures on C4 then the Knight would
come to B5 so very very unique where
blankets is playing both sides
Knight C8 Hikaru maneuvering his knight
from the queen side to the king side
bringing all of the toys uh to the
nursery party and the Knight getting to
G6 then he's gonna push E4 at the right
moment I would have even considered
pushing it now but Hikaru says I can
play this whenever I want to let me know
there comes
yeah G3 is is not a Site for Sore Eyes
H3 is is now sensitive the F3 Square
might be a loose and Rook B2 look at
that well-timed infiltration E4 E4 wins
a piece
where he takes D3 oh man this is
exquisite Rook takes B2 for Maxine
forgetting that the bishop Falls with
Tempo he might resign Here and Now
Hikaru will equalize the score just like
that
and look at the body language Naka knows
he's in the he's in the float he's in a
flow State now he's feeling himself the
Starbucks and suddenly that Starbucks
came out only when he's starting to win
games yeah yeah yeah so
um yeah like we said this matches uh has
it gonna have a lot of twists and turns
and we've a tied match folks tied in the
five plus one segment the three-point
lead is completely erased it's like two
different matches within the first
segment of of this one match what do you
think is the biggest factor that changed
between the first four games and the
second four games casa
I think knock actually changed his um
openings approach and he actually
changed quickly enough to kind of stem
the tide you know we've had this
different type of rosalimo structure
with this D6 and Bishop D7 and uh We've
also seen him go back to Knight F3 B3
which is kind of Old Faithful for Naka
and these types of uh time controls and
I think now that's probably where he's
gonna have to stay
and I don't want to be the Monday
Morning Quarterback here but we knew
when this match started 0-3 that this
was not going to be a blowout no there
would be no adoption no there was not
going to be an eight-point match after
the five-minute segment you don't win
the SEC five years in a row if you can't
recover from a bad start
yeah and the position on the board here
is really interesting to me because
uh I think it's more kind of in White's
favor essentially white has the bishop
pair and black kind of typically curls
up into a ball and turtles a little bit
in the structure so C5 is a little
surprising to me I'm trying to open up
the position I think that favors the
Bishops
C takes D5 would be the Natural Choice
for me because C takes D4 is not
possible or probably not likely I think
the two Rooks there would probably be
favorable over the queen
um with uh The Rook infiltrating in that
way so I'm not a huge fan of C5 here
typically when you you you trade that
light Square Bishop off and then you
turtle and keep your pawns on light
squares to kind of restrict that Bishop
on D3 but this is a totally different
structure man it's almost like Black is
a grunfeld player I mean it's almost as
if you know C5 is influenced by his real
opening desires
um I like your idea your point is well
taken C takes D5 will probably see
Knight takes D5 aiming for B4 and then
white could make some sort of calm move
like moving the queen away to the side
or dropping the bishop back but there's
a lot of tension good call Casa CDs on
the board and uh Knight 65. Bishop A3 oh
interesting yeah no basically getting
out of the way of the bishop on G7
because there were some Dynamics with uh
with even after Queen E2 where maybe
you're not as impressed with the bishop
on B2 but yeah Queen dates a very Savvy
move entertaining Queen A5 getting out
of the pin and Black's gonna argue that
the activity here on the C line is gonna
compensate the bishop pair kind of
deficit if you will and queen A5 here
might be a great move
I actually think for that reason uh
Bishop A3 was a mistake I think Hikaru
forgot about the queen sliding into A5
now the bishop on A3 is a Sitting Duck
and after Bishop B2 there's night before
and white is on the cusp of losing a
minor piece I think he has some sort of
Bishop C3 move there but Hikaru is
already hanging by a thread yeah you're
gonna have to show some really unique
geometry here to hold this together and
essentially the problem here is it's
just hard to defend this A3 Bishop
because the bishop G7 is bearing down on
that diagonal that was the the benefit
of C5 is this bishop this grunfeld
bishop all of a sudden asserts itself
but now he's gone to E4 but the medicine
might be worse than the disease here
after the Knight jumps to F4 and again
because the Knight makes contact with
the dark with the light Square Bishop
the dark squared Bishop can't drop back
to B2 now I think fbl is gonna Massacre
the king side and then pick up the
bishop on A3 at his leisure
yeah so Knight takes D3 you might say
well isn't A3 Bishop hanging but the
after Queen the xt3 the knight in D7 was
hanged so that's why Knight takes H3 was
played instead and yeah now black is
gonna have a material up advantage and
the C5 Pawn is still loose
tough to hold this one the E4 Pawn as
well is not going to complement the
light Square Bishop on D3 well at home
nope and so you're really gonna have a
hard time making it you know more than a
fat Pawn so he's got a pleasant Choice
does Maxine between taking the bishop
and taking the C Pawn but I like the
Desperado sack on F2 and for newer
players how do you find a move like
Knight takes F2 well this is a classic
situation where two pieces are hanging
at the same time so the logic is if I'm
gonna give up that piece anyway let me
take out as many enemy soldiers as I can
before I give that piece up so it's
pretty simple logic Knight takes F2 is
on the board it's a technically winning
position for maxim materially and
positionally Casa with these massive
dark Square weaknesses all over the
board
yeah and well spotted too after Knight
takes F2 that you're still hitting
another minor piece with the bishop on
D3 so even if you tried to move the
bishop away from A3 it wouldn't have
solved anything and so essentially here
black just has to consolidate they're
you're up only a pawn up but basically
White's Pawn structure again is mangled
those school children are not holding
hands the field trip is gone awry bad
things are happening and really you just
have to just make sure you don't allow
any funny business on F7 that's the only
thing I could see that's potentially
dangerous is the queen and Rook lined on
that file but it's very unrealistic the
problem when you're playing Hikaru is
that you know every enemy that's at your
door starts to resemble a three-headed
Hydra like there's some pressure on F7
you think that there's already some
other mate there's some pressure down
the C file you think you're going to
lose all of your pieces that's how
Hikaru gets under gets in your head
because he is so good at manufacturing
chances in Lost positions so ampl taking
a large chunk of time
trying to figure out can I get away with
the move Knight takes C5 and the answer
is yes but one of the details caused
that you have to foresee if we could
pull up an analysis board here really
quickly I'll be brief after Knight takes
C5 there's the scary looking move Rook
f2c1 now don't take on D3 and blunder C8
with a check instead you play B6 and now
the move B4 gives up the bishop on D3 so
this lateral contact between the queen
and the bishop had to be foreseen but
MBL steers clear of this and instead as
we go back to the live board he's
decided to take on C5 with the Rook any
blundered Knight T4 now he's worse
because rookie for traps the queen oh oh
no and it's insane because I would have
just over protected the F7 Square kept
my pawn and said you know what that's
good enough for now
um and so sometimes that concrete path
like the one Donya just outlined is
narrow enough that you say you know what
I have a a you know a safe Advantage let
me just play with that and
mvl missed this critical detail uh in in
the variation and it just turns the game
completely now Casa I kind of regret not
pointing out rookie I was gonna point
out that hey Rook A4 almost traps the
Queen the queen only has B2 so what's
the point of 94 it's a double attack
you're attacking F7 and slicing off the
contact between blacks bishop and the B2
Square so that you were threatening Rook
A2 now look at Hikaru two intermezzos in
a row takes F7 takes E6 threatening mate
recapturing the rook and I think that we
might be close to delivering some sort
of smothered mate uh especially if black
plays Rook to G8 here which I think he
has to
yeah I was wondering if Queen B2 might
be uh two another detail yeah
jeez Bishop takes C4 it's time to
recapture the rook and will we see the
Knight coming to E5 for Maxime
if the Queen's can somehow be traded I
mean I know it's extremely far-fetched
there are some outside possibilities of
holding this position so I've Rook gate
is a really good start for mvl and uh
yeah again I think if Knight takes G7
you throw in Queen B2 check there
um and then you capture with the queen
on G7 and you're almost almost out of
the woods but again white would still be
in the driver's seat
I can't believe how quickly this turned
around Hikaru he spots everything on all
sides of the board Knight F3 to D4 was
sexy but he still has a tough technical
task ahead of him he's probably
contemplating
a move like Queen takes D7 because I
mean you're salivated the prospect of
the Knight maneuvering to F7 with
Checkmate but it's a cumbersome maneuver
it gives black too much time I think he
should keep it as simple as possible
just take back on C4 and chill and it's
funny I see some really cute mating
ideas with Knight G5 and Rook H1 oh
there's some really really fun Dynamics
Along on with H7 whether it's Rook takes
H7 Mater H6 and queen takes G6 and then
Rook takes queen queen H7 made so
there's all types of fun with Knight G5
so I see how that could be attractive I
think he's yeah he's definitely thinking
about it I mean imagine winning a game
like that
Knight G5 and queen takes G6 and that's
a lot of Hope chests but Hikaru is a
perfectionist he's going to calculate it
as long as it takes for him to find to
calculate this out to its clear
conclusion but he's under a minute
Bishop takes C4 exists it's Old Reliable
just play that move Hikaru though he is
taking a Monumental think here believing
in his ability to convert with only a
couple of seconds on his clock and he's
been in snacking on food as well so you
know yeah
this hasn't been all about making the
right move okay Queen takes D7
he wants this Knight G5 maneuver
what's wrong with it
I've said VL has 35 seconds to figure
that out it beats me goodness Casa I
think he's got to go roxy8 and Rook f8
cover the F7 square at all costs at any
cost yeah and I think keeping the queen
B2 check move in reserve is going to be
really important because in some
positions you might actually Dart the
queen back toward f8 instead Rook C3 oh
Knight G5 he wants H6 what a
cold-blooded move wow creating look for
his King
H6 here what gotta do it composure by
mvl but H6 Rook H1 okay no Rook have
fate
but a check on F7 cost and then Queen E6
sets up a threat of smothered mate oh my
gosh Queen E6 is coming
yeah and now 96 Queen G8 is gonna be
problems
black might have to go H6 he goes Queen
D5
has to push the H Pawn does MBL or bring
the queen back wow that is incredible
resolve just to say the discoveries
don't kill me that is incredible
stealing nerves there and that that was
the reason why I had to put his Queen on
E6 Casa sorry go ahead oh and his Hikaru
worse or better
worse
no better he's winning
what is going on here this King has
needs to escape Square he should have
played H5 a while ago
all right defending seven oh protect E7
and Bishop F6 this is and then the king
can come to G7 at some point
and somehow Maxime is blockading the E7
square and he's restricting White's
Knight which is moving to D5 and now
it's getting sharp again this might be
Perpetual this might be a Perpetual here
Queen F2 G5
and it's Queen trade and who's better in
this ensuing end game it's probably a
draw White's banking on this passer
and I think we're liquidating now into a
dead drawn position yeah and it's very
important that the Knight on D5 doesn't
allow the king to cross the Rubicon
there and attack these six Pawn because
if it did then black would be winning so
both kings are kind of tethered off from
uh from targets and hold on hold their
horses
but so does white so does white
the fork Maxime has lost it white will
promote with check
with check and Hikaru wins the game this
is insane
and look at naka's reaction he is pumped
he is beyond thrilled that that happened
wow wow oh my God that's why you can't
go for the win like this when you've got
two seconds we need to do an instant
replay I don't know if we should do if
we should do it now or before the break
but I want to show the move that
actually led to this pandemonium in the
first place and that was Rook takes C4
as we see the players there and mvl will
have to come to terms with a one point
deficit casa
unbelievable and I just want to quickly
show this position right Rook takes C4
was a panicky reaction and Maxine
actually had to find an insane move
Bishop to F6 in order to open up the G7
Square the top Engine line here is
insane Rook C2 King H3 Queen F7 how did
mvl not find this very simple line Rook
takes F6 Rook C7 that ladies and
gentlemen is the top engine 9 and black
is slightly better
that's what Hikaru does too that's what
he makes you find
it's it's honestly kind of appalling you
could play as well as mvl has played and
be down after the five plus one segment
it's it's really it's traumatic it's
it's uh it's flabbergasting it's it's
all of these things and um
wow uh just an insane turnaround
absolutely insane and remember all of
this started with Knight to D4
threatening F7 and threatening the queen
mvl will be kicking himself for that one
but the fact remains it's a close match
Hikaru has not just diminished the
three-point deficit but turned it around
he leads by one now we will go on a
break folks but before we do we wanted
to wonder if you wish that your
financial systems were as fast and as
smart as the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase well
they can be check out coinbase.com
update the system today that's
coinbase.com update the system or use x
Glam coinbase in chat to learn more but
we will learn more about this
fascinating second SCC semi-final but
first we'll let the players catch a
breather we'll have the three plus one
segment for you but first a short break
we will see you in a bit
ha
ha ha
foreign
[Music]
almost daily I love them honestly
because they taste great I know that
sounds silly but not everyone wakes up
looking forward to taking a supplement
and I legitimately do because they're
tasty obviously they're phenomenal for
you or I wouldn't be taking them a few
years ago I went completely corn free so
I don't eat anything that has not just
corn but any type of corn syrup which
these days isn't everything and so I
spent a lot of time looking into these
supplements whether it's pre-workout or
just to like start my day
and I spend a lot of time looking into
that stuff and there is nothing better
than the ingredients in it hey
phenomenal for
any type of thing you're looking you're
looking for whether it's just adding a
little more whatever you want to call it
fiber vitamins all the stuff in them you
know into your diet if you're lacking
some of that if you're legitimately
looking for energy and and ways to kind
of start your day on the healthy side of
the of the bed if that's a thing or the
chess board but uh no the the
ingredients in this stuff is the highest
quality if you are looking for anything
to boost your diet
around it's it's awesome I also actually
take this liquid stuff which is vitamin
D with vitamin K these days if you're
not taking vitamin K with vitamin D
you're basically wasting your time if
you didn't know that Pro tip you gotta
have vitamin K with your vitamin D so
anyway I uh I love ag1 whatever reason
you might be looking for it
it just tastes so good like honestly I
have to be careful not to drink too much
because then that can you know can be
too much for your tummy but it's
phenomenal tastes good good for you good
energy makes you feel like you're
starting the day fresh and I recommend
it check out ag1 right now
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
speed Jazz tournament can you keep up
that's crazy for the last seven years in
counting the best Blitz and bullet
players in the world have flocked to
chess.com to prove their worth at this
format dominant display one of the best
SCC performances that I have ever seen
in seven years dozens have tried but
only two have ever worn this Crown
Magnus makes it look easy he wins the
speed test championship
who will be this year's Blitz King
welcome to the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase
[Music]
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship semi-finals presented by
coinbase the iconic orange walls the LED
pineapple the car nakamura's background
is known to all and the score of the
match is known to all Hikaru holds a one
point lead after turning around a
three-point deficit that he faced after
the first three games while hikaru's
dominance his hegemony in the speed
Chess Championship is not a secret to
anybody let's take a look at uh his
semi-final performances since 2018. I am
Casa Corley that three-letter word there
that's repeated five times tells us all
that we need to know
talking about the dubs uh yeah he has
been truly incredible in semi-finals
matches and he's never lost one of these
and really what's most impressive is how
quickly things can fall apart
um shout out to chinua chibe I read that
book back in the day when I was a kid
but anyway it's just remarkable just the
adjustment that was made and how quickly
it was made impressive stuff
oh Things Fall Apart amazing book
um I read it as well actually you're
absolutely right Casa and the fact that
an SCC match is three hours long it
gives you this false in the end no I can
get behind by a couple points it's okay
I've got another segment that's maybe
true against most players in the SEC but
when you fall into a hole against Hikaru
or Magnus you just get this sense of
hopelessness and part of where that
sense stems from as we're about to
commence uh the hour of three plus one
is the confidence you can see it written
all over hikaru's face these players
they don't relax when they start winning
a match they just get better and better
and better Things Fall Apart the center
cannot hold and things spin out of
control faster and faster
and I think one of the adjustments or
takeaways from VL is going to be he's
going to be have to be a lot more
judicious in these time scrambles where
he's taken risks to collect points and
it hasn't worked out otherwise he's
played a pretty good match thus far and
here we go we are back not quite in
russellimo land instead of uh Bishop
b5bops for Knight seats Knight C3 and
now playing Bishop B5 what do you think
of that difference Donya well first of
all I have a small pun for you
um uh how did Nicholas get picked up in
the airport in a Russell limo
throw the tomatoes at him okay we need
to get back to the game though because
crazy stuff is going down Hikaru with
what I think I've heard referred to as
the Siberian trap where you try to
deflect the knight from F3 but mvl was
not born yesterday and he slices off the
connection between the queen and the
pawn that is a pawn sacrifice I I'm even
afraid to ask Casa what happens if you
take it yeah basically the huge problem
there is that after Queen G3 which I
think would happen after the exchange of
nights and then uh night uh and then
Knight takes E5 you have a scenario
where it's hard to reinforce that Knight
on E5 I mean the d-pawn would be pinned
and so okay here we have it on the board
F6 not not my favorite uh move to play
uh and uh yeah you're trying to justify
the extra material this is a move to me
though that signals that nakas really up
for a challenge and D3 is a tepid
response it's
response I actually
was inaccurate if we could pull up an
announce board early on here at sikaru
continues to expand on the queen side I
think he's managed to consolidate mvl
rushed Queen G3 uh so as we pull up that
board Queen to H5 apparently was a
strong move because why because it also
prevents F6 it forces the Knight back
and it opens up the e-file what is White
gonna use that e-file to do well there
are all sorts of checkmating ideas Queen
d8 you can go D4 you could even consider
a move oh my God and look at this I'm
not saying that that's a good move
life's not gonna take but that
epitomizes you know the extent of
White's initiative I mean look at this
position oh my God awful it's
aesthetically so beautiful for white
because none of the pawns can advance
without being uh without compromising
the king or the queen so just oh my God
oh my goodness I mean this is love
behind the kids I'm the wife that is
insane that is
wow fast forward fast forward get away
from me get away from me
this position is way different than we
have on the board and um yeah I think
again white has us you can maybe argue a
slight lead in development here maybe
more than slight but the problem is
black spawns are doing an excellent job
of covering the business squares the D5
squares cover the E5 square is covered
um there are some Phantom tactile
Dynamics on D5 but it you know nothing
really too Concrete in here and black is
taking more real estate uh with the C4
so huge problem for white in the short
term and the long term all of White's
real estate is in foreclosure right now
the bank has seized all of mbl's assets
including the e-file including the
bishop on A2 very sloppy play by Maxime
after excellent opening preparation the
reason Queen H5 was better as you saw
artfully put at Casa is it took care of
the business squares right yeah now you
still have the IFA ostensibly white
still has the elements of compensation
but he doesn't have the same purchase on
key squares in the center in fact icaro
is actually running circles over him in
the center I think hikara might now
trade on e4 and he would really really
want to complete his development with
Bishop C5 he does and he gives up G7 but
even if the queen takes G7 The Rook on
h8 is defended and I think he can just
take on E3 and take back on F4
yeah and I wouldn't be surprised either
if King E7 happens you connect the Rooks
the king is quite secure in the center
to me and then the Rook can come to G8
and start to do some damage there but
it's not necessary and queen takes F4 is
a much much more appropriate response
end games now are gonna be awesome
because this Knight on F7 can jump to E5
it's just an unassailable outpost
there's no Pawn on the D or f file for
white to challenge it and this bishop
182 is just Buried buried under Rubble
indeed it is and black just has this E5
Square waiting for the Knight it's a
nice seat by the fireplace glass of cab
and uh actually might need a glass of
Cabernet after he goes down in this game
because this match this is what we talk
about Casa it's starting to get out of
control
yeah already it's just again this was
the first time the opening went truly
badly but it wasn't it was one move
really that turned it in in many ways
this queen H5 move so but yeah this is
uh positionally just this is positional
domination this bunny 2 is just
doing absolutely nothing and white will
might have to sack and exchange just to
revive it but that's not going to be
enough compensation so just taking a
page from your book yeah and it's and
it's brutal here because again it's an
enduring problem and so okay this is a a
sacrifice born out of desperation and it
will not be sufficient by any stretch
there are just too many targets for the
black Rook to run circles around this
bishop on C4 and there's there's too
many Avenues right it's like you can
hold the e-file you can maybe hold the G
file but I just feels to me that
eventually Hikaru is going to find some
way uh to make inroads not suggesting
that it's easy but he's got how many
different Avenues got the f file he's
got the D file he's got the pathway
through the dark squares with his King
so he's got all sorts of counting roads
he's got the freeways and White's got to
keep all of that closed and Hikaru
trying to build another freeway down the
H file maybe it's a fortress maybe he
can't make any progress here but I think
he can just walk his King to D4 yeah the
game within the game here is just to not
allow The Rook any infiltration on uh
white-sided board that's just going to
be so much harder said than done and I I
think the Breakthrough essentially will
probably happen with the Rook nested on
C3
um uh I think at some point if you can
get in this Rook c8c3 on under the right
circumstances it's just going to be hard
okay and this is actually even easier
the King on F3 is Tethered to G3 the
black king will just walk down the
yellow brick road of the dark squares
and uh
but what you need to make sure is that
in response to Bishop E8 you need to
make sure that you can hit the C2 Pawn
so Hikaru does drop back to G8 I think
that's the optimal Square for The Rook
because it's a holding down the bishop
and B ready to move to C8 at the right
moment now after Bishop B5 I think it's
finally time for King C5 because Bishop
B8 can be met with a move like Rook H6
although G4 but okay some counter player
check first and then Rook H6 to prevent
G4 Exquisite yeah really smart although
now the the king can't uh D4 so it's
still tricky Rook H7 Rook G7 deflect I
mean to to make a run for it you might
actually have to sack H5 and that's
really really scary with 20 seconds so
Hikaru still some work to do oh the
bishop straps Bishop it's trapped whoa
you gotta go it's over King E7 and Rook
H6 picks up the bishop and Naka actually
I think was surprised that it was
trapped I don't think he actually
realized right away uh because he made a
he made a face like he did okay here we
go this is a different setup now Bishop
takes D7 was not featuring any of the
other uh Ross limo games we'd had with
D6 and I'm surprised that D3 and C3 is
the follow-up typically when you take on
D7 you go for this maroxy Bond type of
structure with C4 and 9 C3 and then D4
this is a more modest type of uh setup
and I think black has no problems
absolutely and I would throw an A5 and
really get things started on the queen
side not a huge fan of A6 MBL playing
this a little bit more cautiously now
Hikaru transforming the structure and
garnering for himself this D5 Square
just to tie up the previous game I
thought what was so aesthetically
pleasing was the way in which Hikaru
pretended that his only winning plan was
to infiltrate D4 and then the winning
move was actually dropping the king back
to D6 suddenly out of no nowhere that
Bishop was trapped and we are getting a
bunch of Trades here who has the shorter
end of the stick in the end game so if
you're looking at this I would slightly
slightly slightly prefer white at least
before Rook C8 just because the bishop
on C5 seemed better than its counterpart
on G7 but the problem is the Knight and
the bishop are both a little bit loose
at on the C file so I think MBL solved
his problems objectively although uh
yeah it's it's still a tough position to
navigate
a great I think Rook C1 has to be played
he goes with the a rook now eventually
leaving the a pawn without supervision
might be dangerous Knight T4 excellent
move yeah taking advantage of the bishop
on C5 being loose uh just a nice
tactical solution there and uh yeah 92.
now here's a line that has to be
carefully calculated let's put it on the
board folks
Bishops yeah and you see where I'm not
going with this because I think a newer
player might say oh well this is easy
deflection and Checkmate new because
after Rook D1 the Knight suddenly drops
back to G1 and blocks the check so
instead what you're gonna have to do
here is play the move Bishop to H6 white
could actually go back to E1 the line
continues and after Rook takes C4 white
plays Knight takes C5 probably black has
to do this and then Rook C4 with a
slight Edge in the end game so that was
what Hikaru had to calculate and
ultimately he decides against it he
plays Knight takes D4 costs a rook takes
C5 Knight back to F3 and now the
prophylactic move H6 looks like Max seem
now firmly in the driver's seat yeah the
it's it might be seem weird because the
bishman G7 needs a few moves to really
assert itself but basically here Black's
Rooks are a little bit more active the
997 has potential as uh to go to D4
point and if we ever can talk about this
bishop f8 maybe getting the C5 maybe
looking at f2 maybe just getting that
fade and looking at A3 that is a lot of
counter play on whites potentially
sensitive pawns and so slight Edge to
Black here although
it almost feels ridiculous to say that
when you're we're talking about Nakamura
for sure but I think the key word there
is potentially right it's important to
evaluate pieces not just on their
current level of activity but also in
what they are capable of under the right
circumstances and you look at this
bishop you say well it's a terrible
Bishop it's biting on granite first of
all the pawn is kind of an extension of
the bishop and both of these pieces are
controlling the D4 square but later on
the bishop does have this very nice f8
A3 diagonal to work with and Hikaru is
faced with a difficult defensive task
there is a tactic with Knight takes E5
technically he wins a pawn but Casa
that's purely temporary and that
actually gives this bishop a lot more uh
leverage over the game by opening the
long diagonal yeah and honestly the the
okay Naka goes for it but really this
eight three Pawn is really the problem
in White's position because this visual
mg7 controls the queening square that A1
square that long diagonal there and if
that ain't Pawn is picked up the four
versus four will favor Black because of
that a pawn and so that's really where
this has to head for mvl and I do like
his time management thus far no time
scramble Zone at the moment although
maybe I've spoken just a little bit too
soon it's important for him to stay up
on the clock I do think A5 might be a
case of many hands spoiling the broth
and he just missed Rook C1 which is an
excellent defensive move he could have
forked the a pawn right away now he
actually will have a very hard time
winning the a pawn without having to
give up his best his biggest asset which
is his Bishop
yeah and I'm actually getting a little
bit concerned here because yeah after H4
which is in this very very astute move
giving yourself an escape score I think
I'd actually prefer to be white in a lot
of these positions just because this
white Rook is more active practically
you can start to harass the F7 Pawn with
Rook C8 Rook C7 and 95 and kind of shape
the tree of Black's King side uh
structure so I'm not optimistic at the
moment
no and some tart decisions here for for
Maxime if he plays F takes G6 well
you're giving white a pass pawn and
knowing Hikaru having commentated him
for as many years as I have you know he
is already flirting with the prospect of
playing for win I I think to ensure the
draw smoothly Maxim should play King
takes G6 in order to keep his pawns yes
they're isolated but in order to prevent
white from creating a king side passer
heads up call by mvl we might see okay
Rook C6 check forcing the king back and
we might see some sort of Knight
maneuver to F5 I would still be scared
Casa yes I would be scared yeah I was
gonna say King 7 Knight H4 and it is a
dangerous position still I think King H7
is very very precise move
um because now there's you know you
basically ensure that if the Knight does
go to H4 there's no follow-up check and
you can entertain Rook a one check
Knight takes F2 and just get your
counter play in time
and I think Hikaru he knows that he can
basically make a draw whenever he wants
to he can make a draw with two seconds
on the clock here
um and so he's still trying to okay E6 I
think is essentially an olive branch
he's technically down upon but because
of how weak Black's King is and because
of how active light's peace tandem is I
think this should be a straightforward
draw though I'm surprised actually that
Hikaru gave up the pawn like that yeah
it's a little bit tricky just because
there's still some A2 and Rook H1 check
combination and that Rook would be
protected on H1 so this is all of a
sudden not getting convenient
oh my gosh and I think he car overlooked
it 94 check and now Knight C3 Knight C3
Knight C3 and is black winning here
that's white with him because oh my God
there's just one Pawn left on the king
side
but look at Hikaru he's gonna go Knight
F5 and he's gonna orchestrate serious
counter play against the Rook is gonna
move the Rook is going to move out
enough it's not enough the Rope the Rope
can move out and then block this is not
enough mvl should win this one and he
has the time to do it and he's done it
hikar just resigning because there's no
way to stop Rook B1 and A1 Queen and
Hikaru doing mvl doing to Hikaru what
Hikaru did to mvl a little bit earlier
in that other end game and are we gonna
get this position again no we're not
going to give Bishop B5 because I okay
now we have a a classical Sicilian not
uh not something we've seen this match
thus far very very interesting
um will MBL go for Bishop G5 which tends
to be the most challenging main line or
will he go for something more tepid H3
that is tepid but is still playable
still reasonable and we'll see now this
shift almost to some type of night or
style setup of E5 very interesting
yeah so this started out as a Rouser H3
definitely not the most common response
this is more positional because I find
it very unlikely at this point that
white will Castle Queen side virtually
no chance of that instead white is of
course playing for the D5 square and
it's hard for newer players I think
cause it to to understand the appeal of
this line for black what I would say is
that the D5 Square it's the most
visually striking elements of the
position but it doesn't tell the whole
story if you've seen how people play the
smashnikov you know the black has a lot
of play on the king side to
counterbalance uh the weakness of this
square but I I still think the white has
a slight Advantage objectively yeah and
the next few moves white will probably
look to play uh castle and C3 to cover
that D4 square and essentially you'll
see the Contours take shape worth
Blackwell the bishop pair typically this
bishop might even drop back to H6 at the
right moment and essentially say that oh
here we go and essentially say that that
is enough compensation for the D6 Pawn
which is surprisedly a pawn that's not
one very much in Sicilians as much as
it's perceived as a backward pawn and a
weakness that's rarely actually won so
um that's what we're seeing here and we
might also see the move Knight A5
lessening White's grip on the D5 square
that might have been underestimated by
mvl also grabbing the other Bishop there
we go and uh
this is going in hikaru's Direction now
I think Knight takes B3 now five is an
option and you're doing you know you're
doing work on the king side we might
also see them move G6 here very very
typical it's very instructive uh The
Rook ad1 was played instead or Rook do
you want to play it instead of Bishop C2
keeping that light Square Bishop because
one thing you don't want to see is white
when you play these structures is a
recapture on D5 with the pawn once you
do that Black's paw majority is set in
motion even more conveniently than it
might be now and there's no pressure on
the D6 hook Pawn so it's very important
for White's Rook to establish on D1 so
that you can recapture The Rook if that
ever happens this is a slightly cringe
analogy but I thought it was effective I
never forgotten Aaron nimsovich and his
stem uh book my system one of the first
kind of uh positional manuals uh he
Compares this to uh going to the dentist
and getting your cavity filled uh on the
house courtesy of your opponent right as
long as there's a piece on D5 the cavity
is occupied by a piece but when the Pod
lands on a weak Square it's just like
filling a cavity right because the pawn
itself is not extracting the maximum
value out of the weak Square so I think
your point is well taken and it's a very
important one for newer players to
understand speaking of squares H4 is not
played in order to attack it's played in
order to increase White's grip on the G5
Square
yeah and it's a bit of a double-edged
move to me because you do soften the G4
Square so whenever you're pushing pawns
always look at the squares of Jason to
where they are now pushed because those
are usually potential weaknesses so push
H4 you look to the left you see G4 is
sensitive that's the cost of that move
indeed but how does black exploit that
and first of all does black reinforce
that square by Shifting the queen over
to d8 because Knight G5 there's a
Cascade effect of white takes on G5 F6
becomes a stronghold for White's other
Knight
yeah and it's funny because the queen on
da does cover G5 it's such a Savvy
little Juke there I don't love the queen
lined up against this Rook on D1 though
I keep seeing visions of of a knight
takes E5 happening at some point if the
Knight or D5 vacate so you know you know
I feel about connected Rooks as well I I
don't love the queen there long term but
does very concretely address the Knight
G5 move
indeed I like Black's position from a
low time point of view I generally am
partial to the side with the initiative
but Hikaru recaptures with the pawn he
keeps his Pawn structure intact but what
a heads up move by mvl Knight G5
sacrificing the pawn and I think he
might have the strike F4 which Hikaru
probably missed shattering Black's pawns
and exploiting the X-ray Casa we thought
it was going to be against the queen but
there's also an x-ray against the light
squirt bishop and that's the X-ray that
mvl is exploiting with this move it's so
funny you mentioned this F4 move because
we had a discussion about hanging Pawns
in a king's Indian themed position that
Naco one that came from a sicilian that
became a chagoran and essentially we
said the hanging pawns aren't such a big
deal there because the bishop was
influencing on the diagonal very
different story here there is not really
much of a king side attack anymore and
whites play in the center is the most
dominant feature in this position and
that's what we're seeing here you're
going to see Rook D1 shortly or G4 just
slicing away at White Black's Pawn chain
this is at his finest he is never afraid
to make moves like G4 he knows that
because his pieces are so Superior to
blacks the king is actually much safer
than it appears yeah and this is
extremely extremely high class I mean
it's very impressive now you can even uh
consider going to an end game right you
take on F5 take on e4 uh it's just one
check after Queen G4 check the king can
come to F2 and it's probably fine so I
am now loving all the end game potential
here but uh here we go
mvl has to take this game I think you'd
agree with me this you he can't squander
an opportunity after such a well-played
positional game I would have gotten the
Rook over to F6 I would still get the
Rook to F6 Rook F6 and Rook F7 and he's
picking up more pawns this is totally
winning Hikaru might just resign yeah
and very very important here to collect
the H Pawn collect the H Pawn Yeah
that's enough
yep and he ties the score two wins in a
row for MBL and he wins this one in
sparkling positional fashion yeah really
brilliant stuff and here we go okay
we're back in this uh we're back in sort
of the rossly no not Ross limo and the
bishop B5 Moscow Sicilian Czech land but
again I'm really surprised that uh
Nakamura is not going for the C4 Roxy
bind style gripness instead going for C3
D4 typically these Bishops take on a bit
of a French type of structure black will
play E6 and Knight F6 or Knight G7 and
the light scored Bishops are off the
board so it's a much better version of
these types of structures for black than
is typical so
um yeah I I can recall actually there
was a World Cup tie break I believe
where Duda won the a black side of this
type of structure against Magnus
ah good memory I remember that match and
mvl obviously did not play Bishop D6 he
can't play it now either because if e
takes D5 uh and because of the pin down
the E file black cannot recapture so
instead he finds a workaround but
there's that H4 move again the position
taking on the Contours of their previous
game in this variation where you might
remember mvl went coincide and got
checkmated now he goes kingside but the
drawback is that there is a knight on h8
that and it's literally the drawback
yeah it is truly hilarious to see this
because it really does get redeployed
quite quickly but even so I I never like
encouraging White's h-spawn expansion
with h4h5 and just again we saw upon H6
in a much earlier game in the match it
just becomes a thorn and black side the
entire time and I'm a little surprised
actually that how hard and Chuck in H6
before Knight F7 was played but
regardless uh the Knight is back in the
position and uh you know it's not as bad
as it looks for black guy it's it's
quite tenable actually although F4 might
be a nice Outpost for White's pieces now
it did and he's trying to get his Knight
there maybe his Bishop there but right
now he's got to deal with the pressure
exerted by blackstroke on white skin I
like Maxim's position the E5 Square yeah
it's technically a long-term weakness
but it's very well defended by Black's
minor pieces
and again you know if you just want to
take the temperature in a position
without even knowing much about Chess or
even the rules of the game and all just
ask yourself whose Rooks are connected
first it's usually a decent indicator of
how the game's going and black got there
first
um again it doesn't tell the whole story
but it tells you that you know one
people one person has their piece is
activated and kind of involved in the
game
do you flick in D4 what's your take on
that
I honestly I honestly wasn't wasn't
going to do so just because I think I
think in some lines maybe those pawns
could be sensitive on the queen side uh
particularly the the black pawns that is
on the dark squares I wouldn't be too
keen on it that being said space matters
and now D3 could be a long-term weakness
um uh but um yeah it's a matter of taste
these I kind of like to keep the
flexibility as well and when you play
the D4 move it's it you slightly become
inflexible but your point as well taken
not only is the D5 Square now a
stronghold for white sign there's H6 he
carflex it and might follow up with
Bishop G5 and try to get the Knight
across to D5 practically I feel like mvl
has has brought upon himself a lot of
difficulties he's also down on time
maybe he can get away with Knight C6 to
E5 here targeting the F3 square instead
he trades off the other night and I
think Hikaru is likely to take and
deploy his Knight to F4 and if mvl can
get all of the Rooks off the board I
think with every piece trade Black's
defensive task becomes easier and the
influence of the H6 Pawn uh is
diminished yeah I will say I think the
position now will come down to whose
Knight is going to insert itself more
you know we have this Knight on C6 this
Black Knight potentially it could get
onto looking at the F3 square at some
point that would be a bit scary also the
902 if it gets to D5 that's going to
start to Menace the black king So to me
it's about whether these Knights
activate and uh yeah that was a very
nice uh Chris berman-esque uh sound
effect there Don you know I've seen you
very much from time to time I'm just so
happy you know where it comes from Chris
Berman is the OG whoop guy and that's
where I learned it from and here comes
the Knight to E5 and Black's Knight is
just much closer to the promised land uh
you know it's like in The Hunger Games
when you're when you're stationed closer
to the what is it called the Cornucopia
uh then then your your enemies
um the Knight is coming to E5 Hikaru I
think wants to play Queen takes B7 so
he's simultaneously maintaining contact
with F3 and keeping contact with the G7
Square reducing the activity of black
screen which has to babysit that square
yeah and to me I think you probably
jettison that B7 Pawn to get that
activity I think the Knight on E5 having
the activity is more important than the
pawn but the thing is actually white has
Queen D5 check in those lines after uh
Queen takes B7 which is maybe why mvl
was turned off from it
he takes H6 so he's tired sick and tired
of that pawn but it comes at a great
cost not only is his Knight not on E5
but I think he's allowed Hikaru the
opportunity to trade off all the Rooks I
said that that favored black earlier but
with White's queen as active as it now
is and Black's Queen side pawns as weak
as they now are I thought that the trade
of Brooks would favor white Hikaru
though getting his Queen to D5 and be
all missed that move and he's blundered
C5 he's blundered C5 yeah and now this
Knight has to go back to F7 which is a
tragic tragic uh some place for that
night Queen E6 would have failed to Rook
takes E5 by the way just a blind spot
for maxim he missed that check on D5
Hikaru doesn't even have to rush I was
gonna say but F4 what why when F2 is
being prepared I'm just totally
surprised though because it I would have
been very tempted to just slop off C5 or
F5 take it this this is surprising to me
E3 also is a little bit of a weakness
now uh you know uh-oh I thought MBL
should have tried to get his Knight to
G4 and to do that he had to kick the
Queen off of the pin with Tempo now he's
given Hikaru the tempo and Hikaru can do
it can use that Tempo to reposition his
Rooks and force the black queen onto a
square that is rightfully belongs to the
Knight instead he takes FG Paving the
way for Knight F4
it's also quite remarkable to me Queen
takes C5 Queen takes D4 comes with a
check in so many instances
rookie three and then we'll take over
the initiative
and there's no meaningful checks Queen
D7 Rook F7
94 is mate 94 is mate 94 penis is
winning
this is also winning
all of a sudden the tables turned
completely Hikaru forgot about the E2
Square rookie 2 is crushing also Rook F3
is is probably also crushing but 94 as
well
okay where's the mate though where's the
mate rookie won King H2 and Hikaru lives
to fight another day Rook takes he lifts
to fight another day two seconds and MBL
is losing it Queen G3 Knight G2 hikar is
still in the game Hikaru is still in the
game
oh my goodness he's gonna save it
Knight takes D3 should be tried he face
saved it hey you know what you know I'll
say about that in previous games in this
match mvl would have kept that going in
the scramble I respect the decision to
punt on that one and go to another game
because the match is still in the
balance so I actually commend it's very
rare I'll commend a repetition but given
how some of the other games have gone in
those scrambles I'm cool with that I
think we need to bring back the analysis
board folks I'll take no more than 10
seconds to show where mvl missed the
final win because you might be looking
at this and saying what on Earth just
happened don't worry we don't know
either but the last point at which MBL
was winning cleanly uh was here where he
had this move Knight E4 check slicing
off the contact between the queen and
the F3 Square this literally ends in
Checkmate then later on instead of Rook
takes H1 he could have played this move
Rook takes up or why with the idea of
Queen H5 Knight not F3 but H3 H3 F2
Queen H1 made try that on for size folks
how did he miss that with five seconds
left against icaro yeah the former uh
tactic with 94 was the one you just
gotta have you just gotta have it um but
uh again uh that wasn't I mean I I think
it was the right decision to take the
the repetition when it finally was there
at the end oh at that point yes okay
back to this game
very very different position we have now
we have I believe something that must
have come from a Kalashnikov
um which is a setup where uh the D6
square is also or the D5 square is also
under White's control but black has
excellent counter played the dark
squares and we see that now with the
even the dark Square Bishops coming off
the board but you see the D4 squares
soft the F4 square is soft so it's
really not the end of the world that the
D6 Pawn is a bit of a weakness yeah and
unlike that previous Rouser game like
you pointed out White's control over D5
is is far less impressive
um you could drop your Bishop back to E2
but don't forget that black also has the
D4 score Hikaru I think just trying to
eradicate his weakness with D5 he solved
all of his problems this is dead equal
yeah and if you really were to pick
anyone you you might SL ever so slightly
uh prefer black because typically in
Sicilians if black is you know gotten in
the D5 Square D5 break cleanly without
you know incurring any damages usually
that's a great thing and so uh black is
is fine but you know so is white it's
not nothing's dramatic has happened yet
yeah maybe like you said a smidge smidge
preferable The Marvelous smidge maisel
but I don't think it's anything
significant and I think Bishop B4 is a a
heady move by Maxime to take Black's
most active piece off the board in a
classical game you know the players
would already start looking at each
other and preparing the Peace Accords
but in a Blitz game you know exciting
things might still happen yeah and how
do you try to win this game as black
well you first of all you you have this
H5 H4 business which we see Alpha zero
style in all types of positions and also
the king side Paul majority in
particular with that e-pawn and and end
games
sometimes it starts to assert itself
Queen C6 is a surprising choice to me
though that is not a move I think that
would be on the radar of the vast
majority of chess players myself
included not just because it looks like
it blenders upon although it doesn't
because C2 hangs but because after Queen
C6 ostensibly black ruins this Pawn
structure but Casa in Rook endgame's
Pawn structure works much differently
than it does in the middle game and
isolated pawns are not inherently bad in
end games I think hikara will try to
prove that by grabbing control of the D
file yeah I'd also contend again that so
you see this E Pawn I mentioned before
the that majority is going to be harder
to mobilize than White's Queen side
majority and this is a little dangerous
here because black will play moves like
H5 H4 G5 and start to Bullet constrict I
like Rook D3 just because he's trying to
fight for the file but black has boa
constricting potential here
and just not to harp too much on the
pawn structure but the point is that
white doesn't have the Firepower to
access or to attack these isolated pawns
because white has to babysit the D file
and will Hikaru take the ambitious route
he does take an ambitious route not the
one I thought he would take with C4
sacking the pawn opening up a pathway
for his Rook to be too but of course The
d8 Rook will also be hanging so after BC
what is his intended follow-up
I'm not sure I'm I'm actually not sure
oh he is taking on uh not thing he would
take but yeah Rook B3 is extremely you
missed it I think this was missed yeah
yeah he's rolling his eyes here because
now you essentially in uh you can sort
of indirectly guard the C4 Pawn because
the Rook on B3 can't be recaptured
without strengthening White's Pawn chain
and defending the C4 Pawn so a bit of a
missier now white might be able to play
for a little bit
and four oh man he's like Frankenstein
he created his own monster
uh did uh Hikaru he created the B file
now Rook B6 Jack and white is making
gains on the queen side I spoke too soon
I said those pawns were unassailable
they were impervious to attack well the
last thing you want to do is open up a
file and give white an Avenue toward
attacking those pawns I would just grab
A6 and Rook D4 can be met with rooked A4
keeping his loot keeping his Loot and
it's a three on zero on the queen side
and again it's still tricky because the
pawn structure for wearing the queen
side is not ideal but uh it's and black
does still have a majority on the king
side but this game really turned thus
far with the C4 move that Nakamura
played trying to sack a pawn but it
actually kind of activated White's Rook
so White's Got to Now consider A4 Rook
A1 and starting to make the majority of
his own there's a lovely tactical idea
with Rook to E1 threatening Rook takes
E5 and Rook B5 and they'll spotted it he
found the right moment for it and I
think Rook B5 is coming next even if
black drops The Rook back which he will
this is technically winning now for
Maxine can he cash in before the break
yeah these Rooks are gonna essentially
play Pac-Man with the pawns and so
that's why Nakamura got up he's like you
know what this was not my finest hour
oh my gosh this was an incredible game
it was a dead draw it was peaceful and
suddenly Hikaru gets over ambitious Mrs
Rook B3 and mvl is back on top in this
match how many twists and turns Casa
have we had and we're barely halfway
through the match
if you're not entertained I don't know
what's wrong with you this is just
incredible back and forth Affair thus
far and I think we're gonna see a few
twists uh still to come
incredible Casa this has been such a fun
match to watch and the best part is that
it's a one point match the best part is
still ahead mvo lead seven and a half
six and a half folks we hope you're
enjoying the speed Chess Championship
presented by coinbase and we will be
back with the second part of the three
minute portion on the other side of this
short break
[Music]
oh my God it's the same thing every time
why did you on passant bro I swear to
God ompeson should be enforced
yeah it's the same thing every time why
did you on passant bro I swear to God
onpassan should be enforced all my
friends watching and this day is taking
forever play faster if I can move this
poem backwards it would basically be
Checkmate oh and draws are dumb
I should be able to flag him no matter
how many times I repeat moves 1400 years
and it's the same game every
time you know what it's time for some
updates I'm tired of this I'm I'm doing
it still mate is now a win for the
player who gets stalemated you're
welcome Eric Rosen hey it's the Rosen
trout pawns can move backwards why is
that and never not been a rule pawns
come backwards now every piece should be
allowed to on passant what that's not
even possible how ship it dunzo update
enter
Wiseman ending there's just two kings on
the board what is this Purgatory this is
so awesome what we're doing here guys
we're changing chess why can't people
just move however they want whenever
they want
wait what Checkmate do I not get to move
from now on C4 actually explodes
pawns are weak no more pawns can promote
on the first move update
I'm not sure I made the users as happy
as I thought I would maybe chess doesn't
need an update Financial systems do need
an update though coinbase is working on
just that re-envisioning an entirely new
Financial system that is decentralized
and fully transparent thank you coinbase
for sponsoring competitive chess and
making events like the speed Chess
Championship possible go to coinbase.com
update the system today to learn more
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done a
hundred percent ad-free Bliss
forevermore whether you're following our
events on site or on stream type the
command connect in the chat and thank
you for helping bring these shows to
life
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
on the face of Hikaru Nakamura who faces
a one-point deficit in this semi-final
match of the speed Chess Championship
presented by coinbase against the
Frenchman with three names well as we
pointed out at the beginning of the show
these two players faced each other in
the 2020 SCC final and the match started
very similarly to the one today Hikaru
with a one point lead after the five
plus one portion the three minute
portion was all tied and the bullet is
where Hikaru really took off right now
mvl is dominating the three-minute
portion which Hikaru himself called his
best 60 Minutes of the match How
concerned is Hikaru how many twists and
turns Casa are we gonna see in this
match
yeah and the question for me is whether
he's looking forward or is he looking
back
um with some regret over what transpired
over the last few games
still very much in the balance but I
think we're gonna see several more
twists and turns Donya and this match
can be divided into four stages first
the three-point lead by MBL then second
stage Hikaru comes back gets a lead
himself then mvl ties the match again
and now mvl seizes the momentum with a
one point lead with two victories in a
row can Hikaru take that momentum back
from him and keep this match close keep
this match tied going into the bullet I
think Casa that Hikaru would most
certainly not mind a tie maybe even in a
one point deficit Because he believes
that he can pull away in the bullet once
again
yeah uh I think mvl needs to kind of
widen the Gap here uh extend the lead a
little bit just because he needs a I
would say he wants a little bit more of
a cushion heading into the bullet but
we'll see how things develop
indeed and we have another Moscow
variation once again I'm Bill covering
with the bishop and once again we get
this king's Indian attack type I don't
know what to call the spawn structure
you know it's it's like an old friend
you recognize his face but you don't
remember if you went to elementary
school with him or he was an old
co-worker like what is this
yeah and it's really surprising to me
that mvl is going for this position
where he's encouraging the H Pawn
forward because it feels like
practically speaking that H Pawn gets
stage six it just you know tough to deal
with but he's saying oh no no big deal
and we have the first deviation here
from NACA with D4 which is very
different than what we saw in previous
uh previous games because it potentially
creates some iqp scenarios
and I'm just that night on h8 actively
bothers me it causes physical pain until
it gets to F7 which it does and I think
it's really interesting that the players
are repeating the same openings but
every time they're managing to get a
slightly different structure
yeah and it's funny here because I would
not be surprised to see Knight B1 and
Knight C3 this Knight on D2 is a
terrible terrible piece right now uh you
know Robert would say oh the pawn on D5
is restricting the Knight on D2 and he
would be correct in saying that we see
it so often F4 it was that necessary
he's trying to carve out the F5 square
but
no man not totally necessary I don't
think this is bad for black per se I
just don't understand the necessity of
giving that pawn away Enfield has shown
a predilection for this F6 F5 mode which
he played again this game now he's
probably going to I mean whatever you do
if you're black you have to keep control
of the F5 score at all costs and he does
that by bringing the queen to F7 and
targeting the H5 Pawn Hikaru might want
to drop this Knight away from F3 to
reinforce that pawn maybe back to H2 I
don't know what do you mean who's better
here who's who's playing for the
initiative you know I would say that you
know I would say that black is fine I
would say it's probably about equal I
like now that this bishop redeployed to
B6 just keeping an eye on the D4 pawn
and this now and C6 can always reinforce
the one on F5 and go 97 so I actually
think if the blockade can't be lifted on
the F5 Square it'll be all right for
black
Rook to D3 Hikaru bringing the beef in
and over protecting the D4 Pawn mvl
could centralize his Queen on e4 and
just as I say that he does Rookie one
guarding the queen preventing Bishop
takes D4 which now fails tactically uh
because you know the queen will fall and
then you'll lose whatever piece appears
on D4 time for a patient move for Maxi
maybe something like rookie 7 Rook F7 I
don't know yeah rookie Samurai F7 I also
am still looking at 97 Knight F5 as the
maneuver but it needs to be timed up
right maybe the Knight stays on C6 for a
while just because it freezes the E3
Vision maybe exchange sacrifice petrogen
Style on F4 yes Casa cordless Style
but not yet not yet we need more
ammunition and that's why the Rooks get
doubled
okay Queen trade anybody Queen trade I
mean the exchange sacrifice is not just
possible but I think even more probable
after the Queens are off the board
because these two pawns are very likely
to fall Hikaru doesn't have much of a
choice I mean I guess he can play Queen
F3 and keep the Queens on the board and
he does keep the Queens on the board I
may be fearing that exchange sack but
he's gotta go back yeah I don't think he
saw Bishop d8 because this is uh not
ideal
maybe King G2 just an improving move I
don't I'm not so sure the exchange
sacrifice is enough just yet like it
looks extremely attractive but I don't
know
I'm pushing an agenda here I just want
to see Rook takes F4 yeah I'm thinking
that if you have the Knight on G4 maybe
you reinforce it with F3
um and then you get the D4 Pawn but whoa
now you're allowing
Queen H3 potentially
or queen E4 again
okay I thought Queen H3 was a golden
opportunity for black to expand on the
king side instead 97 now Queen H3 loses
its luster because it walks right into
the lateral X-ray and mvl just kind of
taking the slow approach and saying as
long as I have control over the F5 score
Hikaru has no active plan here
it's a good result here for black I
think I actually would consider shifting
gears and playing on the C file you can
entertain like Rook C8 and Rook okay
Stephen uh and try and get some counter
Play Over Yonder
um and I don't know it seems like some
counter play
you know the issue with 97 is that black
is no good spot to put a screen he wants
to get get to get rid of it and play
Knight F5 but you've got no good Square
for the queen because Queen E4 is a
little bit flimsy and then once you play
Knight F5 you actually could lose your
queen and so mvl trying to open up a
little bit more real estate on the king
side now he might try to go after the
spawn with Knight G8 how about that and
he does and G6 was a winning attempt uh
this is a very aggressive winning
attempt because it was not needed uh and
now naka's gonna try and say if you pick
off that pawn I'm gonna get counterpone
the H file but now G5 is a possibility
and oh and there it is not what I
expected it when you least expected it
but it might be my beef with it now is
that the H Pawn is on the board the
black king is much weaker in my
estimation than the white than the white
king I just don't think the timing was
right I don't know though Bishop takes
D4 there goes that pawn I think a lot
will depend on whether Maxim can find a
good spot for the night right now it's
happy to be on its initial Square I
actually don't remember if this is the
G8 night or the Knight that was
originally on B8 I agree I think
practically this is a very difficult
position to play he's just allowed an
unfavorable Queen trade and I think
Hikaru might be taking this game if he
finds Queen H4 was there ever any doubt
there we go and again it's all about
this H6 Pawn I would have been in love
with the exchange stack if the H6 Pawn
was off the board but as long as that
King has back rank problems it's hard to
entertain that working out
that's a great call Casa I I think I
overestimated the sacrifice at various
points but this here included once the
Queens disappear these massive holes in
Black's position start to manifest
themselves black just doesn't have uh
the the ammunition the Machinery to
protect everything The Rook is coming to
E1 I think black is dead lost here yeah
uh and again this black king has massive
back rink issues it's just it's just
entombed there so a rookie one is is
going to be easy enough and E6 will drop
shortly they're off they're after then
the whole Position will collapse like a
house of cards Rook B3 Rook takes B7
also possible you don't even have to
rush with a rook take I would throw in
Rook B3 first Hikaru is gonna do just
that I think Rook B3 is such a typical
Hikaru move going for perfection even
when Rook takes E6 will suffice yeah
we've got great observation you know the
man well I do I've played too many games
with him yeah and again E6 is still uh
hanging although Knight d8 is uh what
what you have to avoid so that's why
Rook D7 was played first
it's so easy to squander the game up
until the very last moves we take it for
granted uh that these players convert
winning Advantage Warcraft seven by the
way oh he just takes D5 also good and he
ties the match and an infuriating loss
for Maxine because he was driving that
game for a lot of the middle game forget
all of that we have one a60 Cara back to
his roots
and it's so funny because whenever mvl
starts to feel himself and he he tries
to really go for it it's when things
rebound um if you know the time
scrambles or the the playing for for a
win and those last uh last few moments
he should have been a little bit more
patient there and here we go we've seen
this a6c6 business in previous matches
that um nanka has played and I have not
seen a white player yet punish the setup
and so I'm curious what what in your
opinion Donya is the best way to punish
this A6 C6 business because I'm not so
sure the advanced structures these
Advanced cairos are the right way I feel
like you should just develop and keep
tension well I'm gonna answer by dodging
the question at first and I'm gonna
share a famous story with uh E4 A6 uh I
think them oh and by the way you've got
to be very careful their Knight takes D7
yeah
but I think Hikaru might have sacked The
Exchange there with something like BC in
1980 though and it's only karpovic the
European Team Championship he faced the
move 186 from Tony miles and he lost the
game this was a classical game Tony
miles the flamboyant British Grandmaster
defeated Peak karpov with E4 A6 except
he played it more traditionally with uh
B5 and karpov uh rumor has it was
incredibly angry after that game he felt
disrespected but nowadays I think A6 is
almost turning into a full-fledged move
it's not actually that bad although if
you look at this position Casa you would
be for sure this is that bad yeah look
at this
whites Rooks are connected we see it as
an indicator all of white speeds are
excellently placed except that Rook on
H1 which can get to E1 with quick with
speed with alacrity and essentially yeah
this is not I'll be shocked if Naka
survives this one and there's this idea
of just shoving the F Pawn up the board
and and sizzling initiative down the E
file so first to move the queen maybe to
H5 close your eyes and F4 F5 is going to
be devastating it would be so nice if
black could Castle unfortunately you've
already moved eurook a thousand times
yeah and if you think about how black
could maybe turn this around it would be
because white messes this up but frankly
uh White has to you know essentially
mess up going forward with this attack
here but it seems to play itself I mean
f45 is so so nice
um in fact I actually wouldn't have gone
Queen G3 I probably would have gone
Queen H3 but um it does freeze the
bishop
well you asked how A6 should be punished
I show you this position I'm we're gonna
play some Pictionary I'm just going to
show you this but charades
yeah yeah
um
so just just a rough spot rough spot
man there's just no moves and not all
lost positions are the same you know
sometimes you're losing but you've got
counter play here you just have this
total feeling of helplessness as you
watch White's fplawn Ascend up to F5
smashing through the center in a
classical game I think resigning would
be an option in a Blitz game I would try
King d8 close your eyes and hope for the
best after F5 all right I like Bishop B5
as an attempt to try to kind of evacuate
and and kind of stem the tide it's just
not gonna work the idea might be Queen
C6 and King D7 and trying to hold on the
light squares it's just gonna collapse
uh and yeah Bishop G7 is the way you
initiate those proceedings and now we're
gonna see a resignation because Rook H7
F takes C6 and queen G6 picks up the
Rook what a game 20 moves and I don't I
think we might not see another instance
of one ace something tells me hikara
might want to retire that opening for
the uh duration of this match
yeah and here we go we have this 983
business again but it's really uh C3
Sicilian Vibes and again this is usually
what you see we saw Knight B5 siding
earlier normally you go D4 and after CD4
you go Knight B5 to threaten the fork
and that's typically how this goes
um although Queen E4 check here uh might
be a little bit of a difference I'm not
sure oh man I think that was actually a
mistake by Hikaru I analyzed this pretty
recently uh if we could pull up analysis
board now we're gonna see long Castle so
we're actually going to see a similar
position uh and ignore the double x
squim this is a typical move you're just
threatening uh four con C7 what I think
Maxine should have done is taken
immediately and after Knight B5 long
Castle is really really bad for black
and the for White and the reason why is
that you can't play Knight takes D4
because suddenly after E5 the queen on
D1 is undefended and if instead you take
with a Pawn on D4 and after E5 black
gets a raging initiative due to the
bishop coming out to B4 so a big miss
here actually in the opening by right
Maxime after Hikaru messes up the move
order instead what's the difference now
the difference now is that the queen on
D1 is defended and the movie five no
longer works it in fact it just drops
the bishop
yeah and I must confess I wasn't aware
of that detail but it's funny that you
see whoa 97 here this is C4 a problem or
um you know the problem might just be
Knight takes C6 and then trade queens
and snag upon himself I've had good
breakfast but he takes on F5 instead
that is helpful because now there maybe
Queen takes F5 maybe keeps things
together oven there is 96 check
but then you could trade oh it takes a
knight D5
sacrifices you know you know
um but uh but yeah it's funny a lot of
players and Magnus in particular have
been using the C3 Sicilian as a as a
weapon particularly in uh in in
scenarios where they have a lead and so
it's uh it's interesting to see uh Naka
go for this and um a lot of players
aren't actually bringing the bishop to
F5 I've seen recently a lot of players
are going E6 Bishop E7 to him to win the
position that way so maybe that's kind
of what's giving it its flavor I think
the C3 Sicilian is in the category of
openings that have has like a split
personality you can play C3 as a very
solid weapon against the Sicilian if you
if you're in a must or not must draw but
if a draw let's say wins a mini match as
it does in the World Cup that's why
Magnus played it against kukesh but you
can also play it very aggressively it
was my main opening uh for several years
when I was below 2000 and I still play
it regularly in Blitz and it's a very
combative weapon if you play the main
lines so here I think Hikaru playing it
combatively he's playing it for a win
but I feel like with the trade of the
night for the bishop and the opposite
colored Bishops black should be able to
hold the draw even though White's got
the three on one on the queen side and
that might present long-term Danger
yeah 93 was a must and essentially I
think the E3 Pawn is going to be a
Target and the queen side of the king
side pawns G2 and H2 might also be
potential targets and as you can see
Black's Rooks are gonna jump into the
position just a little bit quicker than
whites and so
White's willing to jettison the E3 pawn
and still play with the majority and
it's gonna be an interesting position
but I I would actually prefer black if I
had to choose anyone to be honest
yeah I mean Bishop takes C3 threatens
Rook D2 Hikaru
will deploy his Bishop on D3 and will we
see Hikaru drakamura and Maxima dragrave
or will this game spiral out of control
Black's clock is spiraling down to zero
right now that worries me he doesn't
take the pawn what why not why not
Bishop takes C3 I thought was just Derry
Gore and now
B4 and white carves out this nice little
window for the bishop on B3 rookie two
though
oh man surprise oh whoa whoa whoa
sacking the bishop
I don't get this I guess Rook dt2 Rook F
Rook B1 wow wow mate he's going for mate
this is pretty cool because even if you
actually don't get the piece back and
you don't get made you're gonna Lop off
enough pawns at a objectively speaking
or practically speaking rather might be
hard for white to consolidate knowing
kikaru I think he might go King A3 here
in order to meet Rook takes B2 with
Bishop C4 and the idea of that is that
then the king is making contact with
whichever Rook appears on B2 uh there
you could also go the other way you
could go to C4 and hide using the C Pawn
as an umbrella but you also could get
checkmated there if we could pull up an
analysis board here really quickly how
could you get mated here well here after
Rook takes B2 apparently the winning
move is Bishop D3 but if you fall asleep
yes you get mated here on D5 so this
would be one way uh to lose the game but
after Bishop D3 B5 is no longer
dangerous and the king is safe as houses
so a apparently King C4 is best and Casa
so important that Rook F2 can be met
with uh Bishop G2 and white gets out of
the pin but I called it I said it and he
played it King A3 on the board but Donya
in the line that's on the board now I
feel that even if you know the a pair of
books are traded if black secures B2 and
H2 I'm just not convinced that white has
any type of winning chances and black
practically with the pawns might be able
to do something you're totally right and
A2 and H2 and how many pawns is he gonna
have let alone the fact that he's going
after White's King but there is no mate
the king is going to evacuate to D3 I
agree Casa I think you just snagged the
h-bawn and say listen I've got three
pawns for the bishop and I've got a very
compact four on one on the king side
yeah I would take black here every day
of the week
um because really Black's King on C7 is
quite safe in my estimation at least for
the moment so uh black and maybe start
to initiate some uh start a majority
with something like H5 in short order
yeah that then we'll see what really
happens but um I don't know when you
keep the pair of Rooks on the board or
moving I actually would move the Rook
yeah I would pursue with Rook D2 I would
go Rook HD2 and now the big moment
Hikaru could go Rook H1 because the D5
square is now protected so B5 is not
mate it's not mate he keeps the Rooks on
the board I would keep pursuing too yeah
he goes back to D6
I don't agree with this again he's going
for it almost like it's a winning
attempt and again the time situation is
not such a way to do it he's got three
seconds and this is a big moment of
truth this will show us how mvl will
fare in the bullet because this will
happen often in the bullet he tries to
trade Rooks at all costs and he succeeds
is going after his King side pawns Rook
Cafe and he's gonna drop Pawns
still some play here maybe H5 but not
the C5 C pawn moves forward H4 always
drop G3
uh-oh four on zero let's go push those
pawns and Rook takes C4 and King T5 and
Hikaru might drop the bishop H4
H4 and G4 has got to be played Black is
winning Rook B6 pinning the bishop
pinning and that's it
he gives it a pocket king G3 F4 F3 F2
March him down the yellow brick road and
that is enough F2 H2 F2 H2 G2 H1 F1 it
is all winning R2D2 point lead
impressive Hikaru can't believe it he's
smiling it's not a smile of joy it's an
incredulous smile how did that happen
you called it Casa the entire time the
pawns decided the game yeah I just felt
practically those pawns could just Mosey
up the board but a car let go of the
Rope a little bit there and he he has
reason to be frustrated so we'll see
we'll see what happens in this one uh
we're back in our in our our
anti-sicilian land in a way we're back
in sort of like a positional positional
night or type of structure where white
likely give up the bishop pair but have
control for the D5 square and the battle
lines won't be drawn yeah well said well
described I mean a little breath of
fresh air a little piece after the war
and I think even more impressive uh than
the win itself is how mvl acquitted
himself in these low time situations
because we're looking forward to the
bullet there's less than six minutes to
go and the bullet is where as I said
earlier a lot of the bread is buttered
so if mvl can stay on equal terms with
Hikaru in time scrambles then he has
every shot of maintaining his lead in
the bullet okay
yeah I was gonna say folks might be kind
of bewildered by that King on E7 but
this is actually something you will see
in some of these distilling positions
when there's a trade on E7 the point is
that you reinforce the D6 Pawn for a
moment with the king and you wind up
going Queen C7 and putting a rook on d8
maybe The Rook on The Rook to E8 or C8
any your king wines are going to f8 and
being fine so it's more of a cosmetic uh
temporary cosmetic Dynamic than a
long-term deal
yeah the king's going to Sephora uh
pretty soon back to f8 as uh MV all
right Hikaru chases the Knight out of G5
posing mvl with a dilemma do you trade
he does will he follow up with F4 or is
he gonna take more of a slow burn
approach and get the Rook to D1 maybe
even put the pawn on F3 looks like
Hikaru solved his problems I might even
take black here because of how compact
your Pawn structure is in the center
yeah I was actually a little surprised
that uh mvl took on E6 but I do think in
you know a Blitz game it's actually
quite hard to keep the central structure
together because it's so hard to push
through D5 so you're basically keeping
it together and trying to play elsewhere
and I think white has a little bit more
freedom in the in the middle game but
knock is doing a great job of holding
the the structure together and it'll be
a question of how White's able to
improve I do feel like yeah you're
demonstrating it that C4 move that
knight redepoint from C3 somewhere else
um tough to move that Knight though and
it's precisely why hikara played Queen
C7 and now the battle revolves around
whether the Knight is free to roam about
the cabinet cars there's no it's like
you know pushing the the the closet and
a bunch of furniture so the bad guys
don't get through the door that's what
that reminds me of now the Knight can't
move at all and now Hikaru can advance
his b-pawn although nvl could nip that
in the bud with before but that also
weakens the C4 Square so very curious
what kind of approach the car will take
here ah Rook D2 prophylaxis nicely done
the end games would be tragic with the
C2 Pawn being weak and white is gonna
try Knight d193 but black is gonna try
and jump on White's King before that
happens with something like Rook G8
maybe uh H for Hikaru actually playing
very positionally carving out the dark
squares for his Knight
do you like this decision I don't I I
think that the night will be excellent
on F4 G3 but I think it'll be hard for
white uh or sorry hard for black to kind
of break through with this Knight on E3
being so well positioned you're exactly
right it's like the then what question
okay you got your knight to the best
Square nice what now and there's
hikaru's answer he opens up a second
front trading off a B Pawn undoubling
white spawns okay one might be something
where all of a sudden the white Rook
uses the five before black does a knight
C2 maybe has the same idea just trying
to stop before but I would keep that
Knight close to E3 it does feel like
that Knight is doing an important job
they're covering some of the business
squares on the king side so
how does black improve that is the
question well right now Hikaru had to
keep his deep on intact by shifting his
Rook over to d8 how many Rook Maneuvers
have we had in this game and a big
question for Maxime do you want to trade
Knights I vote Yes because once the
knights disappear those pawns might be
targeted by White's Queen but he takes a
different route we might get a
repetition of moves here that's not out
of the question either
yeah it's funny you mentioned the Night
Train because it wasn't on my radar at
all
um simply because I thought that after
the exchange it's still kind of hard to
break through but yeah that nitrate does
favor white it definitely favors white
because then you might have
breakthroughs with E5 and if you take
with the G Pawn then the H4 Pawn was
weak exactly and the proof is in the put
Inky card drops this Knight back to G6
he might move it forward again to F4
although not anymore
man so many Maneuvers I feel like the
floodgates are gonna open at some point
the clocks continue to dwindle more so
for Maxime at some point we might get
action either with the okay there's our
action just as I'm talking about it what
a move what a move
what is the idea
what is the idea I don't get it I is it
is it no what
Knight F2 Knight G4 is possible I mean I
think they all should just keep playing
down the pawn but he clearly blundered
something
I think the argument if I can make in
one is that now that Knight on G6 is
actually not a great piece anymore at
least the time being you take away the
F4 Square from the Knight and so you
free yourself just a little bit and I
think that's why you know black doesn't
have a winning position so it's a
positional sacrifice and now there's a
tactical sacrifice in the air with
Knight takes C5 that's what Hikaru was
defending against he has to keep his
Knight pegged to G6 it's tied down to H4
Casa you're right it was a positional
sacrifice but watch out for D5
and it's a hilarious hilariously strange
equilibrium to be honest I I still would
uh would probably prefer black if I was
playing this over the board and here we
go D5 the floodgates are about to open
and they open and is not good news for
maxim under 30 seconds can he keep hit
control over the game I don't think he
can not trade those Queens but what do
you do to E4 is now hanging and the D7
Rook is defended enough times
I would have gone Queen F2 honestly and
then rookie two and just played that
position instead he releases the tension
can Hikaru take back with the rook and
start taking pieces off the board he is
up upon here so any night end game is
going to be lost for white
yeah um I would definitely trade Queens
no wow he did he actually took on D5
first this gives
mvl some chance is still to hold I think
absolutely chances to hold Black's pawns
are still weak Black's King is still
weak Rook A1 Rook A7 and it's a three
result game but he allowed e42 allows E4
oh man you can't have that now now the
floodgates will open with F3 F3 check
and the king is driven back into the
corner
oh no no no
yeah this is uh you know this is
problematic it's over just like that mvl
had a shot he loses the Knight he loses
the game and what a big win for Hikaru
Nakamura to conclude the three minute
portion he's not happy but I think he's
happy on the inside that he's not facing
a three-game deficit right now
no question about it he knows he just
got away with one a little bit and we
are basically in I think an ideal
scenario as viewers uh for this match we
essentially have a situation where nanka
is trailing and has to really be at his
best in the bullet segment that's gonna
be awesome if you told Maxine that you
would have a one point lead going into
the bullet I mean he would accept that
offer without a second thought of course
that final game it was infuriating but
the fact remains let's not miss the
forest for the trees it's an excellent
hour of three plus one mvl wins it by
two he erases the one point deficit that
he started with and now has a one point
Advantage folks we have 30 minutes of
incredible bullet action to go casa as
you said we cannot ask for a better
finale to the semi-final
no question about it lace me up coach
I'm ready to get back in the game ready
to watch this is going to be awesome
my god well we will go on a break but
before we do that we wanted to remind
you and take a moment to thank ag1 a new
partner of the SCC ag1 is your daily
support of key Health functions for
mental performance to energy and the
immune system it's the one product that
does the work of many to find out more
visit
drinkag1.com chess or use exclamation
mark ag1 in the chat we thank hg1 for
sponsoring the sccn we will give the
players a chance to drink their ag-1 as
they prepare for the most important 30
minutes of their SCC Seasons folks you
are watching Hikaru Nakamura taking on
MBL to determine who faces Magnus
Carlson and we will be back with the
finale of this fascinating match in just
a couple of moments
[Music]
thank you
hi I'm Grandmaster anishkirik and
welcome to Latin repair toys
[Music]
the so-called Latin Gambit is horrible
F5
Knight takes E5 this is not how chess
has played he played too many moves with
pawns and the Queen and didn't develop
his light pieces
and it's Knight E4 this is a very
important trick to remember many people
fall for it actually Knight to B5
brilliant ID a b and queen G7 and after
Cafe Bishop H6 Queen C5 and F3 and
surprisingly Queen F2 is almost
Checkmate but it's not
wants to be solid we go for uh
aggressive for the kill if your opponent
wants us to go for the kill we play
Simple chess and just use the fact that
they have more space in the center
clear-cut plants and nothing to worry
about
[Music]
smell chest is coming to chess.com
enchant your pieces with one of two
spells jump or freeze players start with
two jump spells and five free spells
which we charge after five moves you may
cast your spare whenever you wish before
making a regular chest move jump is a
spell cast to one square wherein if
there is a piece on that square other
pieces can jump over the Charmed piece
the freeze spell is cast over a three by
three square area and the pieces in this
area are temporarily Frozen in place
to defeat your opponent
see what supercell and chess.com have
cooked up in our new variant spell chess
dropping on September 1st
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Nakamura has blown through his
opposition at the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase but
now he faces his most difficult
challenge yet he Trails this semi-final
match against Maxima Sheila grab with a
score of eight and a half nine and a
half going into our final segment the 30
minutes of one plus one now of course as
Hikaru himself has pointed out as we
know statistically Hikaru has built the
biggest leads and extended his leads
consistently in the bullet segment from
a number standpoint it is hikaru's
strongest time control look at his
bullet Chess Championship numbers Casa
these are incredible scores I'm having a
hard time reading that third name uh but
I'll let you take it from here
yeah I mean this is the time control
where hakaro typically flexes and he's
gonna have to flex in this match because
he's trailing and in fact he has trailed
going into the bullet before and
actually won both times so this is not
unfamiliar territory for him but he's
gonna really have to dig deep and pull
something out today because mvl is
playing very well
but man that last game of the
three-minute portion so big we should
point out that that one second increment
makes this a very distinct time control
from one plus zero and oftentimes Casa
paradoxically players actually over
adjust we see them playing too quickly
to start the bullet segment one minute
with a one second increment is actually
a pretty generous time control you can
sometimes take 20 30 seconds on a single
move and I think it's going to be very
important for maxim not to overdo it
yeah and I think another Dynamic too is
MBO has shown himself to be quite uh
quite legitimate especially in these
time scrambles but it's usually when he
has a little bit of an edge so I like
him still to maintain that that time
Advantage when he gets down under 10
seconds because a card throws out so
many tricks so many potential ways to go
wrong and I think that's actually how
Enfield has given up some points okay
here we go guys seat belts fastened 30
minutes of bullet to determine who faces
Magnus Carlsen in the finals will mvl
complete his incredible run at the SEC
the first game features a anti-sacility
and another
rosalimo type structure we've had quite
a few positions uh Casa where where
Hikaru has targeted actually where both
players have targeted this week D5
Square
yeah it's not all about the Benjamins
it's all about the D5 square and that's
what we're going to see here again this
night went on a tour to France to get to
that E3 square and it's to essentially
buttress the control of that square and
that other night on D5 so
wow this should be five whoa It's a
tricky one uh and then the night will
eventually tarp out that is not
something you see every day Hikaru going
for checkmate with the Knight on F5 but
his Knights could get tangled in in the
mass of pieces and pawns 98 is the very
heads up defensive I mean never mind let
me dial it back all right peace peace
suing for peace MPL is suing for war on
the king side and here we go the
position's about to open up and I think
it will actually slightly favor Black
who's a little bit ahead in development
if that 98 moves the Russia connected oh
no
and he's allowed a completely positive
transformation for I look at how weak
that F6 Pawn is Queen H4 Knight Queen H4
Knight G4 that was shocking
and that's bullet so there's still
plenty of game but yeah F6 is
chronically weak and and Bill just
forgot to take on e4 he allowed hikara
to lock up the king side now a big
moment Rook F2 such a careful move
preventing the Bishop from dropping into
E2 and now an all-out assault on the
d-pawn on the f-pawn mvl has to play
perfectly uh to keep himself in the game
and we're probably gonna see some type
of rookie 3 Dynamic if I had to guess
but Knight H6 is also an idea all right
The Rook lift another way with Rook F3
Maxine trying to engineer some counter
play on The Queen side he's doing his
best but he's too slow oh man Knight
takes E5 goodbye
Knight G6 yeah there's a lot a lot of a
lot of things in ruin here and uh yeah
this this uh this queen is uh in Peril
oh by the way oh by the way you could
have taken the bishop agar finding a
different path this is going to be
design time
Knight F6
Bishop G7 mate and Bob's your uncle that
is enough exactly and that was a
concerning game for Maxine he mixed up
the move order there in the middle game
you can't do that against Nakamura he
will punish you every time folks it's
zero zero with 27 minutes remaining
yeah and here we go A4 stop B5 we have
uh again this kind of
closed structure F5 is the break that
black will try to organize white will be
well it's kind of doing a good job of
holding off thus far H3 covering G4 so
far so good and unlike the previous game
it's a lot harder for black to actually
achieve F7 F5 the bishop on D3 the
Knight on G3 and the queen all combining
to prevent it mvl beats Hikaru to the
punch both players over a minute on
their clocks but this a much more
positive transformation of the position
than the first time they reach this
structure yeah and blockading the E5
Square seems very unrealistic now if
white could have lifted that E5 Bishop
with something like Knight F3 it's going
to be problematic so white is definitely
the better better better side here I
like F6 though Hikaru now trades on F4
making it very difficult for Maxine to
smash through in the center with E5 now
in some situations white could even sack
with E5 and then put a 994 but that's
very hard to calculate on an ebola game
I would start playing on the queen side
maybe with B4 try to induce more
weaknesses yeah I was thinking A5 was
the idea with Queen D2 but maybe that
allows B5 so
that E4 Pawn was hanging briefly
indeed it was and just in the nick of
time it was missed so uh here we go A5
breaking up the the queen side structure
great call Casa and I think B4 is coming
next it's not far behind whoa this has
to be losing at night F3 instead of
three clutch very clutch oh my gosh 96
wrong move order he should have taken
the Knight first he should have taken
the Knight first and then played Knight
E6 now he just gives up another Pawn 92.
this is a bit too much yeah 92.
maybe bring the queen back being bring
the queen back no you can't allow this
this uh Knight to be kicked this is what
I'm talking about Casa he had 46 seconds
he played way too quickly and made a
very committal decision without thinking
it through and now he is paying the
price hikaru's pawns running up the
board with furious effect Here Comes the
Night everything unfurls and hikar will
take the second game as well yeah and
this Armada of Pawns is gonna be a bit
too much to blockade this Knight in G1
is so poor
okay still trying is unveil's still
poking and prodding and a check on B2
and Hikaru Maneuvers his Queen deftly
back to E5 and these pawns are gonna
decide the game
Savvy just recognizing that if the when
the Queens come off the board it's going
to be hard to navigate so you can't take
just yet but there's the consolidation
is happening Rook takes D3 there was a
big Miss yeah and Bill could have given
himself a chance but he's he's lost hope
he's lost hope he's resigned the game
Knight C2 and E3 and now he's literally
resigned
and just like that
Nakamura is totally erased any deficit
and is he in the lead I believe he is a
point up just like that he's a point up
and what's even more concerning the way
that Maxime is losing these games the
first game he makes a sloppy move mixes
up the move order second game he plays
too quickly again mixes up the move
order and in that second game he got
everything that he wanted out of the
opening once Hikaru starts feeling
confident he starts running away with a
match so MBL I would go so far as to say
casa that this is almost a must win game
for maxim he has to stem the bleeding
before it gets out of control I do not
like this killing H7 it looks a little
suspect to me just with the the opponent
the bishop on C2 bearing down on it um
and so I would like to solve that
expeditiously uh maybe something like
Queen F6 King and shade hold on
what is going on here well let me
disabuse you of the notion that there is
any way uh to attack the King on hm
maybe there is is there Knight takes C5
here I think there might have been Queen
Rook takes B7 and queen takes H6 and you
oh my goodness and another blunder for
Maxime
look it's a lot easier for us to to you
know basically be armchair generals here
it is so hard to read and react with the
speed so I empathize completely
when you're playing Hikaru nothing
describes that experience quite like
sitting in front of him virtually and
playing a game the speed with which he
with which he poses threat after a
threat after threat he overwhelms you uh
with his whole board awareness and look
at what he's doing Knight H2 kingside
move C4 on the in the center on the
queen side laterally diagonally
vertically it's crazy night Chief at
some point Queen takes H6 is going to be
annoying so 94 is more precise now but
Queen day station has been available for
a minute and queen takes G6 will lead to
resignation and there's a two-point lead
ladies and gentlemen
this is what he does this this is Hikaru
Nakamura in a nutshell and this
ultimately costs apart from all the
other reasons is why he's almost
impossible to face in the SEC because
the match can go perfectly you can be up
three points and it doesn't freaking
matter he's going to come back in the
bullet inevitably
and mvo really needs to stem the tide
right now he needs to get on the board
in this segment and it's gonna come down
to you know reading reacting a little
bit better than he has right now he's
trying to trick Trinity five and get a
position that's a little bit more stable
so there's no type of King side attack
but I don't believe you're gonna you're
gonna flex your money through these
types of symmetrical positions
I'm going to show this really really
quickly Rook takes D2 would have won the
game on the spot it would have garnered
two pieces for a rook and then Bishop
takes C4 this is a classic and Hikaru
wasn't even thinking about it Rook takes
D2 you can take with the bishop you can
take with the queen big Miss there that
would have given him a three-point lead
we go back to the live position and this
is looking pretty good for Maxime who's
generating some Queen side play here but
look at Hikaru look at what he's doing
the king's Indian style attack will
strike I would go Rook D1 trade some
more pieces and basically dim any
attacking chances that Naka has I would
yeah go C5 now and A5 A5 and try to
break through although 4g3 is happening
very quickly
oh trade the Rooks Maybe
yeah I would trade heavy pieces all of
them and you're gonna have great chances
on the queen side in the long term and
in the long term costs it to Second your
point you could have later on some sort
of you know Bishop sack on B6 that's
c600 would be transformed into a passer
but for all of that to happen you have
to not allow G3 and he's allowed it and
now oh now Queen H6 is going to be an
issue although you have ideas still to
trade the queen and that is going to be
your salvation here I think you can try
to press this one for a little while if
you're smart yeah you need to get your
king to D3 or Knight to C4 I think
Hikaru is just holding the fourth though
I think this is a fortress and this will
take some more time off the match clock
but at least Maxime is likely to get on
the board at least he's likely to get at
least half a point I think this is a
tough one to defend still this Knight
can redeploy to D5 maybe start to Chisel
away there will be A5 as well it's still
requires some work but careful there
that Knight can get to H4 before you
know it I've lost so many of these end
games to Hikaru where you're sure it's a
two result game and then his Knight
appears up your thrill and you're like
oh my God I found a way to lose
it's crazy that the knights kind of
counterbalancing of themselves right
with this pressure on G2 and A7 my
goodness you're right though Kasich
Maxine is trying that Maxim is trying
but he doesn't have inroads Knight takes
F3 there was threatened
you can you've convinced me the the
Knight on F7 the Black Knight constantly
counter bounces uh White's own counter
play with these sacrifices so yeah this
is a fortress and the question for me is
how long will Naco want to play this out
he's still at 45 seconds so
hypothetically he could bleed out oh
another 90 seconds two minutes we're not
at the stage of the match Knight takes
C5
and Bishop C3 check and you have no
chance if you miss these tactics with 15
seconds left you don't have a single
chance we see the eval bar Rising it's
so much easier for us oh he missed an
easy tactic but nobody's tapping maximum
on the shoulder and saying listen Hikaru
just blundered Knight takes each Bishop
D6 is that a move is Bishop D6 some of
it is and then he finds it he finds it
he finds the impossible move and missed
the easy one and I think he might be
winning and Knight takes B6 and Knight
D5 after Bishop d8 is just curtains
B6 C7
in Bishop d8 Knight D5 it should be it's
the only move and then these pawns will
s will escalate up the board like the
escalator it is it not yet though
because the Knight is heading back to E6
he pushed the wrong Pawn no he pushed
the wrong Pawn he had to go B6 and the C
Pawn would have promoted and now the
problem is this King on E2 is going to
be tethered tonight's sacrifices so you
can't actually support the B Pawn King
T3 Knight takes F3 wins for black maybe
B6 but Maxime has to be careful at this
point
I would not have even gone for this
transformation frankly I think this one
is definitely more favorable to Black
and it's going to take more time off the
match clock Maxine is trying to gain
make territorial gains on the queen side
can he go Keynes e35 King D5 he can D5
that was the move he had to use
opposition and just sacked the Knight
for get those three pawns that would
have been definitely worth it and now
more time is disappearing off the match
clock I think Hikaru is almost flirting
with oh
opposition is going to be tragic here
this this king is more active the Knight
is more active
how are we even very dangerous how are
we even talking about black making gains
here this is getting scarier and scarier
it's triangulation now the Kingwood
Museum King no no Casa Casa the king oh
he King needed to get to G5 the king
could have gotten by force the G5 and
the white king can't cross the Rubicon
Hikaru misses an opportunity there are
still some chances for black though
my goodness this what is this game and
it's still going it's still going
all right
I don't love that Knight on H5 my
goodness
how we're gonna sack the night for the
the two pawns if Allowed by King G2 at
H4 and then King H3 Knight takes you
Knight takes G3 Knight G5 and you're
hanging on by the skin of your teeth
this would have been an even bigger
disaster if Maxime had lost it
what on Earth did we just see and it's
still I mean Hikaru is still trying
Knight F6
okay you do it that way
116 moves and Counting
and now the bleeding begins yeah yeah
he's the furling and unfurling of hands
the the understanding that uh every
second counts now with the two-point
lead that's what's happening right now
the uh record for the longest SEC game
was set in the previous match we covered
together Casa between Hikaru and Fabi
over 200 moves so this one didn't come
close before a bullet game boy did that
take a while still a two-point deficit
for Maxime but he's missing too many
tactical opportunities I think to have a
realistic shot right now and I'm
actually really surprised that we're
getting a Cairo here
um uh because it's not nvl's wheelhouse
per se but okay he has a very reasonable
position thus far
careful there that Rook on E1 was Under
Fire
and five looks Pleasant for Hikaru to
start off the game
yeah yeah yeah for sure
yeah the Rooks are connected we know
about that uh
maybe Queen F3 getting out of the penny
pins obviously Bishop G5 oh no and it's
starting to the wheels are starting to
come off here I think for for Maxime
yeah
it's an idea D5 is an idea rook's lifts
are now on the offing rookie three is
very scary looking
can't give this to Hikaru Bishop D5
Bishop B7 and Knight G6 is gonna pick up
the queen and more brilliant tactics for
Nakamura
and now
take it yeah
and yeah 65 Bishop takes E7 and then
yeah you win you win material
and it's not just about what what he's
playing Casa it's when he's pausing he
senses that this is a critical moment he
takes the time and he calculates this
perfectly Exquisite tactical play
and I don't think black can hold the
draw here in a bullet game
yeah the problem is basically the queen
side pawns if the queen side pawns Were
Somehow off the board you could say
there'd be some Fortress potential but
those Queen side pawns you see Rook B8
curly into a ball they're going to be so
difficult to defend and that's gonna
basically decide the game well said it's
not the material advantage per se it's
the fact that the queen is better
in this type of situation with Once on
both sides but the Karo kind Casa in a
Blitz game you can play unfamiliar
openings and you have time to improvise
my theory is that in bullet you always
should stick to what you know best I
vote Sicilian is a better choice for
Maxime and I think this game proved it
yeah this basically this position very
quickly became the Carol can't so
um hopefully we won't see that in in
future uh future games because the clock
is dwindling dwindling dwindling quickly
and we're gonna get under 10 minutes
very soon still some chances here for
maximity car who dropped his Rook back
he got cold feet I thought that he
should have gotten Rook G5 and F5 now I
think mvl has achieved a fortress yeah
this is the best possible version the
pawns fixed on on F4 and H4 just
allowing the bishop to have great
comfort
why is black pushing all these pawns
still I'm a little confused okay
basically okay it seemed to work out but
I was worried the B5 Pawn would be
picked off it is gonna be picked off and
that was a completely inexplicable
decision for maxim no if it ain't broke
don't fix it leave your pawns where they
are
luckily for him he has the heads up
decision to get his Bishop to F B3 but
look at what's happening now his King is
gonna get opened up decisions so hard to
know how do you deal with this yeah
all right I think as long as the the
white king can't cross the Rubicon it's
gonna be fine but there's gonna be a lot
of clock wasting here and that's going
to be the most important factor rather
than even the game result be still my
Beating Heart G5 King G6 what a
defensive idea for Max game and don't
laugh Casa if Hikaru gets a little bit
too cute and he loses both of his
kingside pawns black is going to be
playing for the win white is going for
checkmate but once the F Pawn is picked
ah oh he blundered the H1
and it's still gonna be I think it's you
still gonna have great chances to hold
just because uh the king is the white
King's going to be hard to get involved
but it's not an easy hold and okay the
king is mosing up to H4
I do not think you could just
I do not think you can sit with the Rook
on the sixth Rank and hold this
and Bishop D1 there he had a chance to
pick off the H Pawn briefly I think he's
just moving back and forth and I don't
see a way for white so for zugs vong
Hikaru trying to build all the clock
right now maybe Queen B8 Queen f8 at the
right moment
to stop the king G7 idea God another
Marathon game this match is just the
gift that keeps on giving isn't it
yeah and again this queen I think if he
gets to f8 is going to be very very
annoying to deal with
gosh
okay still trying hikar trying to find
the right arrangement of the king and
the queen but the black Rook has too
many squares there's H6
but that doesn't really help now H6
Falls
all right and now you just want to get
to the next game because there's no real
winning chances here if you're black but
naka's gonna just have his fun and take
off as much clock game clock as possible
and listen Hikaru knew that he was going
to lose the H Pawn when he pushed H6
that was not a winning attempt that was
a move to prolong the game and we're at
100 moves again
we'll check this but I think this is the
first time in SEC history that we've had
two consecutive hundred plus Move games
and we're nowhere near the game
finishing it's 107 moves we might go all
the way to the 50 move roll yeah and
it's funny because again we were
commenting a match together last week
where NACA actually broke the record for
longest SEC match with I think 204 moves
if I'm not mistaken
incredible we're at 120
and obviously their players are just
shuffling back and forth black could
send the F Pawn off the board but white
always has Perpetual in his pocket I
feel like we just started the bullet
segment and we've already gone through
20 minutes with only 10 minutes
remaining the margin now becomes thinner
and thinner mvl has to win the next game
and just to be clear mvl's not going to
push the F Pawn because it means a
prolonging of the match there's no real
winning chances smart smartly cutting
off the king here on E6 as well
um you do not want to allow the king to
even get close to smell sniffing the f8
square so that's what's what's going on
here and this is the meta game that is
played by Hikaru we're at 136 moves he
probably counted how many moves he
needed to reach the 50 move role I think
they're at that point and now he's gonna
bleed the rest of his clock down they're
somehow under 10 minutes there we are
137 moves and still a two-point lead
this is the biggest game of the match
for maxim needless to say no question
about it and I think he's going long
because he realizes he needs to win
and Hikaru he loves this opening across
all-time controls he's very very good at
the ideas here and I already don't like
the way this is going for maxim I don't
like
what he's doing Hikaru with a very
compact position A4 oh no this is
Manville playing very poorly this game
Knight B6 and Bishop A6 and he's
dropping too many targets yeah D5 E2 is
hanging E3 is loose too fast everything
it's yeah it you made this observation
it's been so true throughout actually
and again it's just a testament to your
bullet experience that you do not need
to go 100 miles per hour the first 20
moves it's just that as MBL gives up the
exchange he's going 300 miles per hour
and it's so hard because these players
are so experienced at one plus zero it's
easy to underestimate how much the
increment changes the the tenor of the
of the game and it changes it
tremendously because it you can't just
play on the clock anymore even with a
single second on the clock Hikaru is
going to win the game if he's got a
winning position what's infuriating here
Casa is that white cannot move the
Knight because of the lateral pin
against the bishop Hikaru brings his
Queen back and this might be the match
unless the next three and it's crazy too
because when F5 did come on the board
for white you felt like there was a
whisker of counter play and you know
Naka basically put on the fire
extinguish sure with the quickness I
mean it was like
so quickly I mean everything just got
doused and it's a three-point lead heads
up move by MV Ultra resigned he had to
do that this is where we need to remind
you folks that if the game begins and
there's even a single second left on the
match clock that game counts for the
score but in order for us to even cross
that bridge first of all Maxim has to
win two games yeah and it's the moment
is now and again uh black is you know
because carving out more real estate
with his pawns he has a bit of a space
advantage and I don't see a ton of
problems for black right now and again
he's rushing the opening and again he
gave up the B5 Pawn King A7
okay still a good position for Hikaru
even though he had a free Pawn he could
have grabbed look at Black's King look
at Black's H Pawn in a bullet game this
is a very hard position to play I would
try to get the Queens off the board here
at all costs yeah 100 that's that's okay
Knight F5 is now massive threat uh
Queen F3 or queen she Queen F3 Queen G5
actually Queen G5 King f8 and once black
gets his King to safety
the position might start turning around
yeah this 9h4 is a little bit out of out
of a pocket there but yeah now it's
corrected one up here
oh
oh my God what a throw
that might that might have been the
match right there
it's like there was nothing to worry
about in the first place that's the
sense you get from Hikaru it's like this
was all planned out to raise the intrake
and then bring the hammer down when push
came to shove
man it's it's amazing because again
MPL has just has played a little bit too
fast in this in this time controls it's
insane to say that because it's one plus
one but it feels like he's got he's just
played too quickly and none of these
criticisms are in any way meant to
suggest that MBL hasn't played an
incredible match which he has an
incredible match incredible run you know
hikaru's bullet speaks for itself but we
are our job as commentators is still to
diagnose the reasons behind the loss
that isn't Hikaru being Hikaru and I
think the biggest reason for mvl's
bullet Misfortune is it his lack of
bullet skill it is precisely that the
first 15 20 moves of every game have
been significantly rushed he's getting
off on the wrong foot and Hikaru is
steering the game into territory where
he's just a lot more comfortable
yeah and it honestly begs the question
for me would if you could take timeouts
uh would it make a difference if he if
he had like a you know Coach's Corner
and could essentially get that problem
diagnosed would the adjustment have made
a major difference
um tough to say but
um yeah it's it's hard to imagine even
if mvl wins the rest of the games that
you're gonna have four four actually
full games to play
yeah and this one is going to drag on
for a long time Hikaru isn't worse here
with that monster Knight on E5 Maxime
hoping against hope now to create
chances but I think he's merely throwing
oil onto the fire now he's losing this
game as well a b oh God another one
also does the trick and basically all of
Black's pieces are better than uh than
the white counterparts um so the 95 was
just a total octopus night and uh all
the pawns are on on white pawns on light
squares you know where white has a light
squared Bishops there's the coordination
isn't there and yeah the Knight could be
picked up and put on C6 slightly
different story you don't know that role
where you can make one illegal move per
game you know there are some parks in
New York City where you might get away
with that but very good not uh not an
SCC
listen you look at the score after
Hikaru picks up this game and it's 15
and a half ten and a half and you say oh
you know yeah that's kind of what I
expected it's kind of a smooth win for
the favorite and you have no idea that
mvl has been leading for most of the
match could have been up by three going
into the bullet and Hikaru erasing a
deficit that seems like it was in
Another Universe it seems like it's not
preordained yeah and when it rains it
pours I mean that's also kind of the
thing we saw yesterday with uh Magnuson
Wesley there is a tilt Dynamic and again
you need to pick up wins so it actually
increases the likelihood that
um it gives your opponent even more
leeway to pick them up themselves so
that's part of the problem
but this is what's amazing about the SEC
it's a bullet uh is there's 30 minutes
of bullet and 90 minutes of five plus
one a sicaro sacrifices The Rook back
not sure what what motivated that
decision oh Rook C4 he's gonna pick up
A4 and uh he's gonna take more time off
the match clock but the 30 minutes of
bullet are always a chance to come back
go ahead Casa Dania the reason it was
not actually totally lost was there was
F takes E3 Rook F1 Rook F5 mate
that was why F takes E3 was so important
I think
and it's a complete blowout in the
bullet mvl hasn't won a single game he
barely eked out one draw
it's seven one seven one in the bullet
yeah and again if MBO wasn't trailing
the score wouldn't basically be this
lopsided I would I would contend I'd say
that his need to win is something that
Naka could truly take advantage of in a
way that is just a little abusive it
feels that way because uh you you
basically have to keep playing and try
to win these games and sometimes you're
trying to win unwinnable situations or
just Cascades and an incredible run by
mvl this year in the SEC he can hang his
hat on competing on equal terms on
better terms with Hikaru in the first
two segments but at the end of the day
Hikaru is incredibly well-rounded skill
set the fact that he plays equally well
across all three time controls maybe
even better as the match progresses that
is the decisive factor and that is why
Magnus Carlson is the only person in the
universe with a similar skill set who
can compete with Hikaru in the SEC and
they will do so in the SEC final H5 by
the way would have won the game pasta
because Knight E3 ran into a fork but
it's a completely moot point at this
point yeah and you know there there are
sometimes moral victories so I would
like to see mvl not stay on Ten and a
half for the remainder of the match but
it this H Pawn was mosing up the board
softening up those those that king sun
how many games have we seen H6 played uh
honestly I mean it feels like it happens
over and over again and the Practical
chances are just massive every time and
we might also get a smothered mate there
Rook G8 was threatened now Rook takes E8
and is there some sort of
is are there Shenanigans with the Knight
getting from F7 to E5 I think there
might be I would trade those Rooks and
with a minute left on the match clock
it's official it's over and Hikaru oh
what a move you can't take the Rook yeah
Quincy won King H2 Knight F7 whoa
brilliant oh Rook Cafe Queen takes f8
yeah yeah yeah playing for the crowd and
he he Nakamura just on camera is like oh
man he didn't go for it he's just
disappointed again Rook Cafe Queen takes
f8 this time with a different made on F7
rookie six Queen f8 Rook E6 Queen f8 is
even more beautiful now it's a threat
and he can do it queen f8 queen f8 queen
f8 queen f8 he sees it
an mvl applauding he applauds and what
else can you do Casa but applied yeah
that that golf clap was merited you know
we we all could applaud at home as well
that was that was nice
this is probably the last game of the of
the bullet segment
um but wow just incredible queen of Fate
moved to nearly finished things I just I
can't believe that it's a six point
match and if hikara wins this final game
he will have won by seven points that's
blowout territory and he was down going
into the bullet
yeah again it's it's truly amazing how
quickly things can change and I'm just
reminded time and time again that this
is really hard and so and holding a lead
against someone of the caliber knock or
it's just really difficult and um
momentum plays such a big role so you
know you have to catch up to speed get
used to the new terms and conditions
faster and unfortunately mvl did not
read those terms and conditions he did
not and and you know I've played Hikaru
thousands of times in in the blitz time
control and you and I've played him in
classical you feel his strength but then
when you face him in the bullet as I've
experienced in the last few bullet
brawls it's like a cannonball
the speed the accuracy as I said the
just constant threats that he makes on
all sides of the board and he might go
down in this final game it makes it so
overwhelming to try to stay afloat you
start blundering you start losing the
thread and just like that he turns it
around mvl though he might score the
honor goal here with an extra Exchange
in the final game
yeah and and it it does again seem so
wild for this to be as you mentioned
almost
it feels like it was not a close match
it totally was it totally was so I'm
almost you know for folks that didn't
watch this one man they're gonna have a
hard time understanding and believing us
when we say well this is this was not
what it seemed I mean it's like a
20-point basketball game except the
20-point lead was built in the last
three minutes of the fourth quarter
it is official he defeats the Frenchman
with three names in a vintage epic SCC
match an incredible bullet performance
and he will face for the second year in
a row Magnus Carlson in what has become
one of the most iconic matchups in
modern chess history Casa this is the
final score that final segment says it
all
yeah folks eight to two in the OnePlus
One and we now are going to be able to
say we're going to get the El Clasico of
Hikaru versus Magnus everyone wanted to
see it and we're gonna see it but the
journey to get here it cannot be
overstated how close this was until the
end
what an effort by Maxime he should hold
his head up high and uh he's not done we
will see him pretty soon in division one
uh of the uh AI Cup coming pretty soon
so he will have more games to play
Hikaru will be playing Magnus but right
now before we get Hikaru ready for an
interview it is time for The coinbase
Savvy move of the day and there were so
many of them Casa uh this was a back and
forth match both players had sparkling
tactical moments but ultimately we have
to Showcase a brilliant tactic from the
winner Hikaru Nakamura this happened in
the three minute portion as they were
going back and forth Hikaru developed a
big attack on Black's King and he
continued that attack with Queen B5
Picasa and VL had seen that and was
relying on the defensive move Bishop B6
how did Beckham wear a break Black's
defensive cocoon my goodness Rook takes
A7 just a bolt from the blue essentially
removing the defender in just the most
gorgeous picturesque way imaginable and
now however you take on A7 your doom is
basically impending if you play Bishop
takes A7 Queen takes B7 is Checkmate and
if you play Knight takes A7 Queen takes
B6 also and the saints come marching in
there's an attack on A7 there's still
the Checkmate threat and uh Bishop takes
C5 I shouldn't be remiss to not mention
that would have left left you with Queen
takes B7 mate in another way so man
they're just beautiful beautiful display
all three captures led to immediate
victory for white and mvl throw in the
towel one of Hikaru nakamura's excellent
wins and that folks was your coinbase
Savvy move of the day okay well Hikaru
playing a very Savvy match and playing
an incredible bullet segment and of
course where would we be Casa without an
interview with the winner we will say
Hikaru up for an interview don't go
anywhere because we will hear his
thoughts on this incredible speed chess
championship match against Maxim Russia
La grab folks we'll be back with you car
Nakamura in the studio in just a couple
of moments stay tuned
foreign
chess is great for the brain but it's
also fun to play and chess kid makes it
easy to have fun whether your child is a
total beginner or a prodigy they can hop
on and find a well-matched opponent from
around the world at any time chess kid
is the safe parent-approved way for your
child to play chess online
chess kid is educational
to kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest bustles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Music]
love playing chess variants or just
looking for something new join us for
the variance Community series
every two months we'll be featuring a
different variant in a series of events
and competitions learn a new variant and
compete against other players for prize
money or just play for fun look for
Community Arenas streamer Arenas and
Championship events six weekly Arena
tournaments held every Thursday will be
followed by a championship event with
cash prizes including a one thousand
dollar first place prize the third and
final weekly Arenas will be streamer
Arenas featuring gifted Subs as prizes
when any of these events to qualify for
the championship the variants Community
series kicks off on September 7th with
King of the Hill we're the first to
occupy the center wins the game but
getting checkmated still loses and join
the variants club today to learn more
about upcoming events how to participate
and much much more
see you in the arena on chess.com
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase the
second semi-final is in the books and we
are all set up for a rematch of last
year's final between Magnus Carlson and
Grandmaster Hikaru Nakamura who joins us
in the studio ikaro thank you for
joining congratulations on the win first
question coming into the match were you
targeting the bullet as the segment of
the match where you thought that you can
make the biggest gains
well I mean I think I've been saying
this problem for the last three years
that I feel like in any match that I
play in the speed test Championship if
I'm not down by more than one or two
games going into the bullet I think I
have great chances to win no matter what
so it's not as though I was targeting
bullet but I did have the mindset
especially after I lost the first couple
of games to start the match where I
simply wanted to keep it as close as
possible um until we got to that portion
yeah speaking of essentially turning
points in the match and having that you
know that small deficit before the
bullet it felt like the the end of the
three plus one segment that really
clutch when you had with F3 check and
you know it was an eventual Queen G3
infiltration In the Sicilian did you
feel like that was a turning point the
way that we felt it as commentators
I mean I I think that obviously in
retrospect if I lose that final game
which I think I probably should have at
a couple of different moments um the the
Whole Bowl situation could have been
different I think I still would have had
great chance to win even if I've lost
that final game but certainly being down
one going into the bullet was um was was
about as good as I could have asked for
considering what I did at the start of
three plus one I mean I I think that in
the three plus one I start out with a
nice one I think with black if I
remember and then I messed up this like
this this Rook the rook and the rook and
knights end game horribly to lose uh
that rookie Knight in three versus Rook
Knight three which I never should have
lost it kind of went downhill from there
and you know a lot of credit has to go
to Maxine for how well he played um and
keeping it together but I think
certainly that final game the three plus
one I did something really wrong in the
opening I think I I think I played some
early Knight A5 and then I had to go
King takes E7 and I mean that was sort
of just a I don't want to say tilting it
was just like get this portion over
pretty much and I was a little bit lucky
uh in that game but you know again at
the end of the day I feel like going to
Bullet if I'm not down by more than one
or two I always will have great chances
do you think it's fair to say that
Maxime played Too Quickly in the bullet
would you say that over compensating for
the reduced time control is a big reason
why SCC participants struggle in the
bullet is there kind of over adjusting
that tends to happen
well I mean I think Magnus said this I
don't know if you said it recently or
was in past secs but I think Magnus said
there's a huge difference between one
plus one and one plus zero and I think
in OnePlus One there's this real urge
just like move very very quickly I mean
I think there's some limit you have to
keep yourself above at least in the
first like 10 to 15 moves
um but yeah Maxine was basically playing
like straight up 1-0 and there were
several games um in the bullet where it
just fell apart really really quickly
for him I was also able to get a lot of
sort of end games
um and there are certain games like
there's this uh game where I got this
whole King side which was closed which
went on forever and it also it actually
kind of reminded me a lot of a couple of
the games I played against Magnus in the
bullet Chess Championship where you're
just maneuvering maneuvering maneuvering
um and eating up a lot of clock and um
so I think Maxine probably over
compensated but once he started losing
like two three games then it's very
difficult because you're behind in the
match if you feel like you have to win
games quickly you don't you can't just
like you can't use all your time because
you're losing time on the clock as well
uh the the timer I mean for the for the
match so uh it's hard to judge but
certainly one plus one it's not as um
it's not as fast as it seems there were
a couple moments where I actually was
able to stop and think for five to ten
seconds but overall it's just very
difficult switching back and forth
between all the different time controls
so mvl obviously proved to be a very
very worthy opponent particularly early
on but we now are going to have the
final that the fans have essentially
been clamoring for for some time just
looking forward to how do you anticipate
uh the Contours or the battle lines
being drawn there what do you think are
the keys for you to be successful in
that match
well I mean the first thing is that I
get to play Magnus a lot I mean I think
I'm playing him on Friday in the final
and I'm playing him on Monday in the
chess Champions Tour as well so I'll get
to play Magnus quite a bit in the the
next three days
um you know I think looking at the match
it's it goes without saying it off to
play a lot better than I played today I
think today um I started off very very
poorly in the first couple of games
Maxine was really really sharp um so
I'll have to play a lot better if I do I
think I have chances obviously I won
last year um but you know Magnus
obviously has been on been on a big run
so we'll kind of see how it goes I I
feel I feel like if I play to the best
of my ability I'll have great chances
especially if I can keep it close going
to Bullet but again you know and if
anyone's guess what will happen
your car we know you're streaming so we
won't keep you much longer we have two
quick chat questions uh before we let
you recover and rest from the match
first one from the real urethra Franklin
do you agree with magnus's claim that
we're just better at chess than the
others quote unquote
well I mean I think you have to put that
into context I think certainly in bullet
it's it's proven to be true you know I
think the one thing that I didn't say
about the OnePlus One is that probably
more so than anything else there there's
a certain intuition like the moments
when somehow I was able to sense when I
need to use time the OnePlus One was
really really critical today uh and I
think two or three of those games and
Magnus also has that ability where
somehow he's able to like Reign it in
and he's able to think at critical
moments so I think the OnePlus One is
definitely or one plus one or one plus
zero it's definitely true I think as far
as Blitz goes I mean I I mean maybe
we're better on average but I don't
think the Gap is is that big so I think
that's slight slightly a little bit of
an overstatement
yeah here's another uh question from the
chat for you Hikaru
krishna21234 is asking did the cat make
a difference in performance
no I I don't think the cap made a
difference at all I think actually the
only thing that that made a little bit
of difference is like when I started out
very well in three plus one um I know
that there's a break every 30 minutes
but at some point I really need to use
the bathroom very badly and so I think
like some I play the C4 I think in the
final game of that three plus one before
the break and maybe even the game before
that was just like I was trying to move
really really quickly to uh to to get
get the games over with so I could go to
the bathroom or we could get to the
break at least um so that's really the
one thing that made a difference the cap
definitely didn't but those of you guys
who are watching the stream watching the
streams in the early days like late 2018
into early 2019. you probably will
remember that cap because I I have worn
it before so it's a hat that I thought
would maybe be a little bit lucky for me
uh probably didn't prove to be lucky but
um I don't think it made that much of a
difference
oh and actually no let me add one other
point the other thing I was gonna say is
of course I think the read the read the
reason no no the reason I wore the cap
of course is because Mac is more that
wore that ridiculous looking uh was it a
puma cap or something the other day so I
felt like I had to had to do the same
thing
fair enough well you mentioned 2018 I
still remember naca's Knockouts and the
orange wall used to be a lot more Barren
uh but how times have changed Hikaru
will let you keep streaming that was
that I mean
can I just add two more things Daniel I
just want to add two more things can I
have two more things
absolutely yeah I just want to add you
know I I think when I look at the um
when I look at the these matches you
know all the matches against mags of
course have been great but I would say
this match is right up there with the
match against England of course the epic
battle I had but there was also a match
against Sergey kariakin where I think I
was down one game in the bullet maybe
Midway through the bullet portion I was
also a really really tight match I don't
even remember what year that was but
this match day was really a lot of fun
and then also the the other thing I was
going to say is you know there's there's
a very famous Steve Jobs quote which is
you can all you can basically connect
the dots Looking Backward but you can't
connect them looking forward then you
know I was saying it's kind of ironic
that the 20 I think it was a 2017 speed
Chess Championship Finals how they
believe in January of 2018 that actually
when I played Magnus in that match I did
play that basically in front of a live
crowd of I think maybe like 100 people
in South Africa and it's kind of ironic
in a way that that was sort of uh
Prelude to you know what everything
would go on to become so uh it's just
thinking about all the match against
maggots the thing about how I actually
played on a computer in front of people
is it's uh it's it's all it's been an
amazing ride so it's just been a lot of
fun playing the SEC and looking forward
to the next match against Magnuson on
Friday
well it's been amazing to watch you play
and uh it'll be an epic rematch from
last year hikara have a good rest of
your stream and thanks again for joining
us for the interview
all right see you guys bye
take care
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
well welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase
unfortunately he was not able to
maintain his lead but it was an
incredible run this year in the SEC by
Grandmaster Maxime Michelle agrov and
Maxime joins us in the studio we really
appreciate it uh Maxime can you take us
through what went wrong in the bullet
you were playing an incredible match at
what point did you feel like things
started slipping away from you
no I knew I didn't have enough of a
living to the bullet so
and then
of course I could have played better in
the bullet but
like you know of course there was this
game where I mean this would take B7 I
was dominant but
like this is a detailed item code that
blows that much anyway I knew I needed
like at least two points and probably at
least three two to have a real chance
um
so of course the
yeah the beginning of the match was
exhilarating but at the same time after
this first 45 minutes
I knew that I that was taking me too
much energy and that I will be able to
to keep it up for for so long
Maxim you think first of all thank you
for this incredible match you you just
treated us too it's just incredible to
watch and commentate
we kind of felt like that that last game
the three plus one portion was a huge
turning point game and
um there was this really interesting
position where you went for F4 which we
found was this incredible kind of
positional Pawn sacrifice where you
wound up taking with the I believe the G
pawn and the Knight was kind of stranded
on G6 how did you rate your chances
there after F4 and did you kind of feel
that was a turning point in the match as
well
no it was blenderizing to miss that GF
was possible because I thought it's
Knight F4 and then Knight F4 and E5
someone and for some reason I forgot
that the light on D6 was protecting the
bomb otherwise of course uh keeps things
slow probably make good drawings
um
but again plus two in the bullet I don't
think it would have been enough
but of course it would have been 100
plus one I mean this
uh uh kind of questioned me of course I
was
like but you can take individual moments
of course the last game of the five plus
one was
crazy A crazy one to lose
but
you know overall I think
if I want it comfortably in bullet and
yeah I mean I do think it deserves a win
of our life
that's not even a question
gotcha Maxim
um how would you say this year's
performance compares to previous years
you made the final in 2020 how would you
rate your overall performance uh this
year
uh well I think I think I paid some good
matches in 2020 as well of course the
one match for a bit Magnus
um but I think this much against Chicago
plates
similarly well as against Magnus of
course maybe in the one person I was
playing better but at the same time I
feel like at least in bullets
Eco is very bad matchup because it does
everything
a bit better than it is not like
something I'm better team than him uh in
bullet like normally it would be small
tactics but okay
against Chicago there's no chance
against Magnus
uh it's different like it can be much
better in other
things but I have at least this one
thing that I can use
uh against Chicago I didn't have
any answer in the bullet section like I
was very happy it was how I played these
Blitz
um
I knew that like if I managed to kill
the level I had in the first 45 minutes
it would have been very interesting but
that was not realistic
well Maxime even though the match didn't
go your way it was fascinating to watch
you were leading throughout and uh
congratulations on an excellent
performance this year in the SEC and
thanks for joining us we'll let you take
your well-deserved rest
yeah thank you
bye
Maxim vashiella grab ladies and
gentlemen he made it to the semi-finals
but he was unable to supersede the big
boss of the malkasa nonetheless he
should hold his head up high he played
an amazing match
no question about it this match came
down to the very last segment and you
know as mvl said he felt like he
probably needed a little bit more of a
lead going into the bullet segment to
really press Naka and that seems to be
uh the story of the match
and another story The blunders right
single digit wonders I've been keeping
an eye on that throughout the matches
and most of the time that one player has
single digit blunders they end up
winning the machucaru played clean chess
he didn't always play the kind of Chess
that were used uh to him playing but at
the end of the day you have to beat him
three times in the five minute portion
the three minute portion and the bullet
and mvl was only able to check two of
those boxes well Casa you know what box
we are going to check the box that says
Hikaru versus Carlson match please and
we're going to be checking that box on
Friday let's look at the bracket
wow we had quite the journey didn't we
we had NACA essentially take down Yu
yangi caruana mvl and now the as I'm
calling the El Clasico Nakamura Carlson
just we're getting the the final that
everyone clamored for and uh it's gonna
be so fun mark your calendars ladies and
gentlemen for two o'clock 2 p.m New York
time 11 A.M in San Francisco and 8 P.M
over in central European Standard Time
Hikaru Nakamura will take on Magnus
Carlson in a rematch from last year's
SCC final this will be unmissable action
we anticipate it to be one of the most
viewed chess events of the year maybe of
all time and for very good reason who
can miss a matchup of these two players
Casa especially when they're in
incredible form and both of these
players have demonstrated amazing form
in this year's SCC
it's appointment viewing I mean I've
said this before I'll say it again it's
appointment viewing and we basically
were treated to two really masterful
bullet segments uh between yesterday
with Magnus and today with Hikaru and
these guys are the fastest players
um they are also the best players and uh
yeah it's just gonna be such a treat and
I have no idea which way it's gonna go
neither do I and neither does anybody
and folks unfortunately the time has
come for us to wrap up the semi-finals
of the SEC but once again the best part
is yet to come on Friday I'm gonna pass
it off to you castle one more time for
your final thoughts but before I do uh
we wanted to make a little bit of a PSA
to all chess clubs you are eligible to
participate in Judith polgar's hashtag
chess connects us Championship clubs
from all over the world are invited to
nominate four players four players to
compete in the online event on October
14th with a chance to win prizes from
chess.com chessable and Judith Polgar
herself join us in celebrating the game
that connects us all use x-glam chess
connects that's exclamed chess connect
in chat to learn more and on that note
Casa I'll wrap up the show but back to
you one more time for your concluding
thoughts on this epic display of bullet
chess from Hikaru Nakamura
well first and foremost I Just Want to
Thank You Dania for being just an
excellent partner here in the commentary
Booth today was so much fun secondly our
viewers always a pleasure to have you
with us and last but not least it's
really a beautiful thing when we have
the best players in the world competing
against one another and you know a
diverse set of formats and that's what
we have in the SEC and that's basically
what we're going to have on Friday so
really stay tuned to that match it's
going to be a lot of fun and the whole
Chess World will be watching
Casa was likewise a great pleasure to
compensate this match with you and to
have courtside seats to some of the best
action that we can find on the internet
folks we thank everybody in the chat on
Twitch and YouTube all 15 000 plus of
you and our amazing team uh of producers
working behind the scenes particularly
hola for making our job much easier
folks who are watching the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase it's
Carlson versus Nakamura in the finals
Friday at 2PM and for now we bid you a
very pleasant rest of your Wednesday
we'll see you on Friday for the SEC
finals goodbye
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign